thank you thank you
good evening and welcome to this meeting
of the council held on Thursday the 13th
of July 2023.
my name is councilor Kevin Lagan I'm the
chairperson of this Council
members are not present we are streaming
this meeting live as well as recording
and by being present in the meeting
you're giving your consent to being
recorded
during each item please put your hand up
to indicate if you wish to speak I will
then invite you at the appropriate time
could I ask that members avoid
approaching the top table as it could
create interference with the cameras and
live stream because the the cables are
just running in the front
please note that the YouTube live stream
sound recording is dependent on the
correct use of microphones therefore can
I ask the winning writer to speak you
remember to turn off your microphone and
turn it off again when finished
please reference a page or a paragraph
number when referring to the agenda
papers and keep your contributions as
clear and as concise as possible
just one other notice from Chairman's
I'm suspending rule 4 part 8 section 3
that the requirement to stand that will
be optional members please thank you uh
we move on to a gender item two which is
apologies for absence uh Tara may I have
apologies for absence please
thank you very much indeed Tara
we move on to agenda item three members
which is the minutes of the statutory
annual Council which was held on the
18th of May
it is recommended that the minutes of
the meeting held on the 18th of May 2023
which is found on pages 7 to 14 of the
agenda pack are approved as a true and
accurate record I moved this
recommendation to a have a seconder
thank you very much indeed councilor
Morgan seconded members uh councilor
white I'm really sorry chairman I've got
one more appallitative counselor labor
thank you very much I'm sorry I've got a
funny tooth yes but with um
well thank you very much indeed for
coming
um
so that's fine we've got that Tara with
the apologies members with regards to
the minutes of the stats sat down on the
18th is that passed by sent
three thank you very much indeed we move
on to the minutes of the extraordinary
council meeting which was held on the
8th of June 2023 and it is recommended
that the minutes of the meeting held on
the 8th of June 2023 which are found on
pages 15 to 38 are approved as a true
and accurate record cancer
uh thank you chairman yeah I'd like to
make an amendment uh to the minutes uh
which is on page 27 the last paragraph
and it should read and he referred to
not being in a coalition but working
informally with other political groups
thank you very much into Council to take
that Amendment members I move this
recommendation Council of my apologies
councilor Stevens
thank you chair a couple of other things
as well
um page 21 item 50 under adjournment of
the meeting it reads that the meeting
was adjourned following councilor
fluka's proposal and that should say
councilor siddles
um it's just sort of a minor detail
really
um there's a few issues with the naming
of the groups as well in tonight's
papers
um the Malden District independent group
has been misnamed as the Malden
independent group and the district
support group has been misnamed as the
Malden support group
um I think we do need the groups to be
named correctly please Clarks I
appreciate it's probably been quite hard
to keep up recently
um I'll raise this as we come to the
relevant pages in the agenda pack
tonight but for now in the minutes we
have on page 19 item 49 in the table the
Malden District independent group has
got the wrong name and page 22 in the
table the same thing
and further down page 22 three
paragraphs after the table it refers to
appendix a which I think is the one on
page 107 correct me if I'm wrong because
it's quite hard to keep track of it all
um and in there the group is referred to
three times as the modern independent
group and they should all say Malden
District independent group please thank
you thank you councilor Stevens Council
fluka
yeah thank you Jim a couple of things
um with regards to accuracy page 18
motion three chairman the
um this was a pretty straightforward
motion that the director of strategy
performance and governance provides
without the exception updates regarding
essexy Evolution to all future meetings
Council and that motion was carried
um chairman but I that's that's how I
remember it and listening to the tape uh
that's that is what happened but I don't
understand therefore chairman why
the decision accounts was as uh has not
been executed and that item doesn't
appear on the agenda this evening
although I'm sure all members do welcome
uh the written report from from Mr
Dodson but I'm in my mind that does not
satisfy this motion but I'm I'm sure you
may cover that under any other items of
urgent business and chairman if I can
just draw your attention to page 21.
chairman and again I listened to take
with today and it does tend to correlate
with what's written in the minutes and
that was chairman paragraph 52
um the chairman advised that therefore
the leader of the opposition would be
jointly held by councilor J.C stilts
District support group and councilor J
driver from the liberal Democratic group
chairman and and that was agreed by
Ascent if one listens to the the tape so
I I I mean either this is right or it's
wrong but if this is actually correctly
recorded then that's going to save us an
awful lot of trouble tonight so Tim over
to you but as I said I have listened to
the tape thank you thank you I just can
reassure members that there will be an
update and bought for us tonight and by
the director of strategy and resources
on Devolution that will follow at Agenda
item seven as for the other aspect of it
what my recollection whilst there was no
decision by Council I advised you that
according to the Constitution it was
delivered them it was it was a little
Democrats and the modern District
support leaders that when we just
declared that just was there was no
decision by Council no that was it
that's that's correct though what is and
what you say cash flowker is correct
there is the leader of the oppositions
currently uh standards councilor J
driver and councilor uh JC stilts
chairman for absolute Clarity then
then the minutes are correct but we are
going to amend
a decision of counsel within the
six-month period which I'm not sure we
can do that yeah uh if one listens to
the tape
and and if it helps Mrs quilts I'm sure
Council won't mind when the Germans so
he can but that was agreed bar sent and
and the way I the way I read it and
others that I've discussed it with uh
that we we actually
uh agreed that these two members would
be the two
um deputies of the opposite Deputy
leaders or leaders of the opposition I
mean I I'm a governance point of view
I'm I'm I'm
enormously concerned
I think it was in resignation
from my record recollection of that
meeting was that that I declared that to
be the two leaders of the opposition
because we were in a situation where we
weren't clear there wasn't Clarity and
for the effectiveness of business that
was a declaration at that time
Castle stamp
chairman um thank you Mr quelch also
said it it wasn't just you Mr quelch
also said it and the advice was clearly
audible on the tape that that was the
instruction that those two groups were
thank you
yeah thank you very much thank you I'll
just come to you cancer and Morgan in
one second to do some of the monitoring
officer to comment please my
recollection is yes I spoke to
the chairman asked my view I gave him
advice according to the Constitution as
it stood
um the leader of the liberal Democrats
and the leader of the Malden District
support group
were joint leaders of the opposition and
then the chairman accepted that advice
and just declared that was that is was
the case my record I don't recall there
being a motion or being seconded and a
vote being taken uh on that at all it
was based on my advice that the chairman
made the Declaration that was my
recollection yep that's exactly they
will come back I think last time of
course hopefully not for the whole
evening
but yeah chairman if that's the case
then you know that should really be
reflected in the minutes uh and again
that would have saved the last five or
ten minutes but you know because it is
very ambiguous
um you know in my mind the the the the
leaders of the opposition have been
appointed and I think if anybody
listened to that tape they'd agree with
me thank you thank you very much
councilman thank you for your diligence
in going through the meeting and the
minutes of the meeting
so with those amendments members
um I move this recommendation
um do I have a second
thank you very much indeed councilor
white again can I agree those minutes
bar sent please members thank you very
much indeed and thank you very much we
move on to agenda item five which is
Declaration of interest to disclose the
existence and nature of any disclosable
pecuniar interests other registerable
interests and non-registerable interests
relating to items to business on the
agenda having regards to paragraph 9 and
appendix B of the code of conduct for
members and members are reminded that
they're also required to disclose any
such interest as soon as they become
aware and the need arises throughout the
meeting thank you members we moved to
agenda item six which is public
questions I can confirm we've not
received any questions from the public
so agenda item seven before I move on to
Mr Dodson has stated um members as most
members would understand that that
previous Council uh councilor Bob Boyce
has been rather unwell on behalf of the
council we have sent a card wishing him
all the very best and I'm sure that this
chamber tonight unanimously wishes Mr
Boyce all the very best for speedy
recovery who says our best to his family
thank you very much indeed members uh Mr
Dodson could I go past to you please
thank you
thank you chairman in fact thank you for
agreeing um my request to to do a a
verbal update regarding uh Devolution
um I don't have a great deal to to
update members on
um but I did want to draw members
attention to the slide pack that I I
circulated to all all members and maybe
just touch on that that briefly
because that does outline what
Devolution deals are
and they are as the name suggests the
Devolution and devolvement of powers and
funding from central government to local
government
it's important as well to I think I
think to to talk about what they're not
Devolution deals aren't about local
government reform or reorganization or
taking funding or powers from existing
local authorities or changing the
sovereignty of local authorities a
Devolution deal
is made with upper tier authorities over
a
fixed economic care functional economic
area or a county-wide area in the case
of Essex that would be greater Essex and
the deal that's that's being discussed
is between
thorac South End
Essex County councilors the upper tier
authorities of Greater Essex with
central government
there's there is a agreement in
principle that should that go ahead and
they've submitted an expression of
interest that went in in March this year
with which government have accepted as a
valid expression of interest and have
opened um discussions around that
um there are now a number of
um
subgroups established to look at that
one of them being governance and under
that governance it is agreed in
principle that the districts would have
a voice within any combined Authority
should it be developed which is by no
means set in stone yet the there could
be three levels of deal
um and it would only be at level three
that there would be a combined formal
Authority with a combined mayoral
Authority but it is at that level that
the biggest prize comes in terms of the
the funding and the powers
um that would be devolved from
government
so I've sent the slides out
I'm happy you know to take take
questions from you when you've had a
chance to digest them if you want to
email me or I'm happy to do a briefing
for all members but in the the first
instance the um the Devolution working
group has appointed at the last meeting
a council will be meeting on Monday
um and would that be an opportunity with
that group to go through those slides in
more detail but also to dig a bit more
into the deal and partic particularly
the opportunities that there might be
um for modern District Council that
arise from any Devolution of powers and
funding from government that might
enable us to to access some of that
funding and deliver projects for the
council thank you chair thank you very
much indeed Mr Johnson
thank you um
uh well Mr Dodgers actually said that he
would like to have an all member
briefing and send the information out so
if you have a shock
yeah but following the the meeting of
the Devolution working group
so I don't mind taking small questions
quickly if if you have something that's
burning
okay thank you thank you Joe sorry I
didn't speak actually and stand up when
I was just speaking as the council
managed to do if we go for um the one
where it's a mayor Authority which I
think everybody knows that's the one
where you're going to go to get the
money has this Council had any chance to
actually look at the risks behind that
the risks and benefits of actually doing
it for that and how much money we're
going to get as a as a council
and if you haven't when
we could look at risks and benefits but
the the ultimately
this Council does not have a say in
whether
the the the deal goes ahead as I said
the deal is between the upper tier
authorities and government
there's a there's an in-principle
agreement that the districts would have
a voice on any governance that that
follows that but in terms of the
agreement we we don't have a vote on
that as search so of course through the
Devolution working group we can look at
the the opportunities and and any
potential risks
that are linked to that and that that's
part and parcel of why that that
Devolution working group is being set up
and thank you Mr Dotson
thank you members just have one more
announcement I'd like you'd like to
welcome councilor Stratton to the
chamber as well this evening thank you
very much indeed
uh councilor white couldn't see you
thank you yeah thank you uh Mr chairman
I mean mine was um when I'd been to the
Divas over my voice when I've been to
the Devolution
um meetings
um it actually said that the money is
all going to be decided pretty much at
the higher tier levels and we're little
more than participants and any funding
will go on need and requirement
um and like highways it seems to be
we're right at the end of the line so I
I really think that we need to look into
the finance side to see whether it's
actually worthwhile for us or not
because we've done pretty well
financially and I wouldn't want to see
us being at the end of the end of the
end of the end so it's something again
that needs to be looked into thank you
thank you councilor White
um
I don't think anything's been well
nothing has been decided in terms of the
the finance share but I want to be
really clear
there isn't an opt-out option for this
Council if there is a if there is a
Devolution deal it will cover the area
of the greater Essex
it won't be except molden if members say
we don't want to be part of it a deal
would cover greater Essex and that's
that's the principle of it because
greater Essex including molden is
covered by Essex County Council who
would be leading the deal
thank you very much indeed Mr Dawson
um members will move on to agenda item 8
which is the minute book this is to
consider the recommendations coming
forward from committees as detailed
below so this please note that the
minutes of these meetings are not
enclosed as they've not been approved at
committee level and there is on pages 39
to 102 the strategy resources committee
which I'd welcome councilor fitick to
take us through gender items 10 and 11
please that's okay thank you chairman
thank you we have two recommendations
from strategy and resources the first is
a gender item 10 aerial special control
for advertisements the recommendation is
that the area of a special control order
for advertisement attached at appendix
one is reconfirmed by the secular
thank you
um the second recommendation is agenda
item 11 business rates discretory rate
relief the recommendation is that the
discretionary discretionary non-domestic
rate relief scheme appendix 2 be updated
to include an additional excuse me okay
members
members they've had the two
recommendations they've been seconded do
we agree these bison great thank you
very much indeed
move on to agenda item nine which is uh
minutes of the meeting of the council I
propose that these mints are noted by a
scent
any comments to be made
excellent
move on to agenda item 10 which is a
statement by the leader of the council
councilor Sydney please
good evening members the results of the
election produced a council that a first
glance would appear to be unstable due
to the number of different groups this
however provides the opportunity for
different political groups to have to
work together in the best interest of
the council residents and the districts
that's what we all need to do as surely
that's why we stood for election
over the past few weeks the different
groups have found a way through and
found a solution for administering the
council we now have the Malden District
independent group in a minority
Administration we all know however that
we can only run the council together
through consensus and collaboration
we all need to find agreement and
demonstrate to Residents that we can act
in their interests
the different groups and those that
stood as independent counts of the
election may have said different things
during the election some have even run
negative campaigns and make negative
comments yet police politics is a funny
game as you certainly would not be able
to get away with that in other
situations
however as the outgoing chairman of the
LGA James Jamison said recently 90 of
what we do in local government has
nothing to do with politics we therefore
move on progressively and work together
in the best interests of the district
I would like to thank the LGA for the
supporters provided during the past two
months we will continue to work with the
LGA and seek their advice and expertise
this will enable us all to change the
organization progressively as part of
that change there will be an away day
next month where leaders both political
and corporate alongside our respective
LGA group peers and LG officers will
work together
this will provide an opportunities for
all representatives to work together in
the interest of the council I'm sure
that everyone wants to demonstrate their
commitment to the council to creating
change by attending it is through these
initiatives we can create change and
also demonstrate to the wider audience
that we want to move the organization
from the past problems
we all want to make a difference for our
evidence and businesses and I know the
Malden District independent group
members feel the same we can all work
together
this also applies in the way that we
work with officers we should be
professional in the way we deal with
officers after all we are all working
for the same organization we need to
support officers in their delivery of
the role and challenge them in
appropriate manner
however in the cut and thrust of debate
we must suspect the difference between
Challenge and confrontation
we have to ask yourself do we want to be
seen as an organization that's
constructive positive and motivating for
both members and officers where we
created culture of inclusivity and Trust
so we have a positive image externally
it's an organization where officers and
members look forward to interacting the
alternative is something we should
challenge
we need to let officers get on and
deliver we have processes and procedures
defined and are Constitution states
officer decision
those decisions and actions are reported
back to working groups committees and a
timely manner we need to let that happen
and build trust with the officers if we
want to get involved in operations then
we should be officers not counselors
if there's a problem or a complaint we
need to inform asset officers and then
the work to take place
to rectify the situation to ensure that
officers can deliver to the district we
have now recently changed the structure
of Service delivery this now creates
distinct roles and structure within each
of the different teams
this will enable the planning department
to focus upon all aspects of strategy
delivery like all authorities it can be
a challenge to retain and recruit staff
in planning molden can be proud of the
work it is doing this area and is
leading on this in Essex and working
with the local government Association
officers are working on a new customer
service strategy in which I'm looking
forward to we're all looking forward to
seeing
the way we interact with residents how
we contact us needs to reflect the
requirements of our residents not all
residents are able to access Services
digitally and we need to ensure that
they can speak to the officer if they
require
we need to explore online interaction
and how residents can interact throughs
through online chat and chatbot
functions in the future
leading from that change we need to look
at how the organization and Leadership
is structured we're unusually not having
a chief exec we need to come up with the
right structures for the organization
and also learn from other authorities
what has worked for them we therefore
ask the LGA for advice on this matter
and they will present possible
structures for the size of our Council
we need to go back to previous LGA
advice and look at how our planning
committees are structured and how we
make planning decisions we also need to
ensure that our constitution is updated
for multi-party Politics as that is
unlikely to change in future elections
the LGA Finance peer review took place
early this year and we're discussing the
recommendations for that later this
evening
all local authorities are under
Financial Financial pressure and we need
to focus on what and how we need to
deliver it we are an authority that is
debt free in the past accounts has been
risk-averse this has also had the
negative consequence that unlike our
authorities we have very little
commercial income
we need to look at commercial strategies
how they've developed and when the
opportunity allows us
these opportunities are much narrower
now and there has to be Complicated by
the lack of resources and appetite for
risk
we need to review our corporate projects
and be creative on what other
opportunities may be able available to
the district we need to look at our
assets and how they are utilized in the
best interest of the district we need to
ensure how and the way we partner with
our organizations and that means taking
up today Asset Management plans and
strategies
if we set up the finance group with its
new terms of reference it will enable
all political groupings and
representatives to make the right
recommendations and explore how we
deliver
we're on a situation where we are in
strong reserves however if we keep
things as they are that will diminish
a local development plans at a crucial
stages of development and we need to
reflect on how what might change on the
mppf at the moment there are 51
authorities in the country that have
caused their local plan
there will always be a Target set for
government we're in a good position in
terms of our five-year housing land
Supply and we need to recognize how that
moves forward in the future
the local development plan is something
that all members can demonstrate their
commitment to is how we will shape the
district it's how we will leave that
impact and Legacy
this needs to be done alongside
protecting our environment we need a
district that is sustainable in all
senses or other words
our high streets and towns are all
attractive places and known for their
character we need to enhance those and
ensure that they are places where people
can come to events and and use them for
other purposes
we need to restore our link to wider
infrastructure and how we connect molden
via Rapid Transit link to the Rel
networked we need to look at creating a
transport Hub with sustainable transport
methods this will relieve pressure on
roads and create opportunities for both
residents and districts in the rural
parts of the district we need to ensure
that the long-term further investment so
that public transport is sustainable and
meets the needs of the residents that we
then we can exploit the opportunities to
have sustainable in the long term
one of those things in terms of the
influence is how we deliver
infrastructure we all had similar
doorstep conversations during the
election about the the local
infrastructure about transport about
doctors about NHS facilities
working with our partners to ensure
delivery and for officers to continue to
lobby as strong as possible the
investment and delivery implementation
one of the key Partners we have is one
modern District this partnership now has
a clear action plan and provide more
benefits in the longer term
we need to ensure that all our partners
to commit to delivering for our
communities alongside ourselves that it
provides the opportunity to improve
health and well-being outcomes for
residents
this alongside the support the council
provides is to be particularly important
at the moment when many of our residents
are dealing with the cost of living
crisis
we need to build that connection to
Paris and town councils so that
Community Network can be built across
the district
we already have the town town and Parish
Council engagement Forum this is going
through a process of change and needs to
become a forum for both clerks and
chairmans and Mayors to meet
representatives from the district
we can then inform engage and Empower
parishes and councils and respond
directly to to their needs
our approved corporate plan for the
period of 23 to 27 was developed over
this year and sets out our Visions our
priorities and our guiding principles it
demonstrates that we're a local
Authority where quality of life matters
and is our aim to improve this over the
next four years it's also vital that we
make sure we have sustainable districts
in Social and economic economic terms
where we protect our characteristics
environment and that we seek investment
for the future
our corporate plan is well evidence and
has a vision that staff are committed to
with clear priorities our service
managers set out the delivery plans and
we as members need to support them in
enabling and meeting the challenges we
face as an authority
expectations of what local authorities
can deliver are higher than ever from
our partners who also face Financial
burdens and no doubt this remains making
some tough decisions about what we can
actually do over the next four years
where we need to ensure that projects
are ready for future leveling up funding
in addition to this we also want to put
a spotlight on the government's
designated District as a priority or
level area
uh we are committed to delivering our 1
million pound UK shared Prosperity
funding plan and continue our efforts to
secure funding all funding was
successful secured for the district is
going to help forward investment
exciting projects
that achieve a great outcome of people
places and communities
it is through Partnerships with other
local authorities that we can engage in
order to improve the delivery of
services both in the district and across
Essex all local authorities are under
Finance special we need to establish
both in the short and long term how may
might work with other authorities to
explore opportunities that are available
we are already in the North Essex
economic board and the North Essex
Association of local councils
it seems that no matter who wins the
next election in the form of uh
something rather to leave the Lucian
will happen this does not threaten the
sovereignty of the council we need to
work with whatever level of devolution
deal is secured to maximize what is best
for the district it's residents and
businesses by taking this approach we'll
maximize the opportunities
finally a statement that has been made
about myself is that I'm ambitious
my ambition is to achieve more for the
district which I hope that is something
we're all agreement
as counselors that's be something that
motivates us all
that we want for the best for the
district district and that we are
ambitious for our residents together as
councilors we need to focus on making a
difference delivering and creating a
legacy that and that's why I stood as a
counselor as I said last week my aim and
I hope yours is is to put politics aside
and to ensure the council works hard to
support the challenges our race
residents are facing
through these really hard times
we all need to deliver on making a
difference delivering on a pledge to
make where we live a place where quality
of life matters
together all these aims ensure we have a
district that is truly sustainable in
all sense of the world delivering for
now and also creating strategy for the
future sustainability for residents
businesses the environment our partners
and those those who come after us making
a difference to the quality of our life
thank you
I can cancel the city
members I'd like to invite the leaders
of the current opposition which is
Council driving councilor stilts to make
a response to the leaders speech if they
if they wish
um so it's completely transparent I'm
going to do it by surname alphabetically
so Council driver please if you wish to
make comments
foreign thank you check can I just check
on whether uh
all three leaders are going to have an
opportunity to speak okay currently at
the moment there's two leaders of the
opposition there is a motion coming
forward later on to amend that
okay
the context within which we find
ourselves and in which the council has
to function is one with no overall
control
the electorate has made their choice and
we have to work with it
from the outsex the liberal Democrat
position has been that we would not at
this stage seek to form a coalition or
indeed to agree any formal or informal
arrangements with other political groups
however we have consistently stated that
we will work constructively with others
to enable this Council to function
we had proposed joint political
leadership of the administration by all
groups but this wasn't supported and so
in the spirit of constructive engagement
we supported the leader of the Malden
District independent group to lead the
administration and we will continue to
do so
there are huge issues facing Malden
District
on the doorstep there is considerable
anger at the way in which housing
developments have progressed without the
associated infrastructure and there are
concerns from residents about access to
council Services which have been
severely stretched
there is much truth in these concerns
and the council needs to do better
but for improvements to occur
the council needs to function
effectively
and for this to happen
we need to work together
there are differences between us and
there will be Challenge and rightly so
but that challenge must be constructive
for too long the image of the council
has been poor with counselors seen to be
bickering and backbiting
this is not going to move us forward
as an onlooker it has also appeared that
councilors and officers
were part of different teams that spent
time warring with each other
faults I'm sure are never just one-sided
but residents deserve better
the lib Dems believe in constructive and
respectful dialogue as I'm sure the
majority here do as well
I hope this can characterize the
behavior of this Council and we can find
ways of working that acknowledge
difference
but look for common ground that can
enable this Council to function
effectively for the residents we all
serve
thank you
thank you Council driver
councilor stilts please
thank you Mr chairman first of all I
would like to state that the modern
District support group is made up of six
independent councilors who are not
aligned with the Malden District
independent group
we look forward to working with the
other groups for this Municipal Year we
will work for the people of Malden our
business and customers to ensure they
get the best service and value this
Council can deliver
we will challenge the administration
when we feel this is not being achieved
we will robustly challenge the
medium-term financial statement and work
with officers to stem the flow of
residents cash from our Reserves
through Challenge and Innovation we will
work with officers to achieve balanced
budgets on an annual basis and to work
with officers as well as all other
councilors to achieve our aims and
visions of the corporate plan
thank you very much indeed councilor
stilts thank you members thank you for
the speeches uh we uh councilor stilts
allow me just to say I think it is
really unfair that councilor Morgan and
maybe doesn't want to speak I really do
think he should and you can actually
allow that to happen if he does want to
speak he should be able to respond
because we're all talking about working
together here but we've got one group of
elected members that have not been
allowed to speak and that's fine if he
doesn't want to do it but I wanted to
and can that be minuteed that I think he
should be allowed to speak yep just bear
with me a second
a very fair request councilor Morgan
please
uh thank you chairman um
firstly I just want to thank the leader
obviously for his speech there's much in
there that was of interest
um and I particularly want to take up
point where he is saying that the
elections provided the opportunity for
different political groups to work
together in the best interest of the
council
the conservative Group which is part of
the opposition
uh will stand for conservative
principles but is above all cognizant of
the fact that it uh represents or we are
members of Malden District Council with
a responsibility towards the residents
in our respective warts
we will oppose but we will oppose
responsibly it is not our wish to bring
anything down and therefore going
forward uh we would like to consider the
there is a sort of a field of
Groundswell of Corporation within the
speeches that we've had that have seated
me and I would like to say that we will
be taking our part in that there is a
lot ahead of us uh the lgp has got to be
sorted out and there's Devolution and we
will hope to work together
constructively to make sure that Walden
District Council moves forward thank you
thank you very much indeed councilor
Morgan thank you members members we will
now move on to agenda item 11 which is
notice of motions we have several
motions members as you're aware on on
the agenda papers so um I'm going to go
through them quite carefully
um as as we move forward so I'd like to
invite counselor um as fluca
um so in accordance with the notice
usually given under procedural for
councilor feluca to move the following
motions duly seconded by councilor Jay
stilts and W stamp thank you
um thank you chairman uh agenda I had
some 11a
um chairman I won't read the motion but
I'll go straight into what I have to say
in relation to it chairman even to the
untrained eye the Tactical and strategic
voting patterns at the statutory annual
meetings by members of the Morton
District independent group conservative
nipple group and others were clear to
see it's worth noting that following the
elections the largest political groups
of the council the conservative group
even with an offer of support from
independent counselors made no attempt
to form a coalition the Constitution
alludes the fact that the second largest
political group of the council forms the
opposition which is contradicted by the
fact that the conservative group is the
largest following several behind closed
door meetings by the aforementioned
political groups a deal was struck
between the parties concerned and others
to populate the key positions of council
from each of the parties involved in
those meetings this was agreed in unison
and by way of a coalition of mines in
summary the key positions were traded
against the support tacit or otherwise
of making the six members of the modern
District independent group a politically
lined party the official administration
of the council it's difficult to argue
that at that point the party so mentions
were not in a political Coalition
whereby they agreed between themselves
to take the key positions just
um interrupted the we were asking to
raise or to deliver the motion as
printed well chairman I'm coming to the
motion and then I'll move it but do we
agree to to say that okay yeah yeah so
so chairman I'm coming to the end anyway
so in the best interest of living the
business and policy a council in a
timely and coordinated way the party's
so concerned should accept that they are
part of a coalition and work together
collectively with officers to deliver
for our residents businesses and
customers the Simplicity of them working
together is for the benefit of this
Council
so chairman on that basis it wouldn't
seem unreasonable to assume that the
balance of members principally the
independent counselors who formed the
modern support group and councilor lay
would be the second largest group of
members and therefore the opposition I
therefore move my motion thank you
chairman so you're moving motion number
one is that correct
okay members the motion's been moved
councilor siddle please uh yeah just
like to point out on Council fluka's
motion there is no group called The
Modern support group so I'm not quite
sure who who's asking to be the
opposition
thank you
so motion one sorry Council uh yes I
think we'll just point out I don't think
Council fluke has may not have a
difficulty in counting but as far as I
refer the largest group that was elected
with the independence and therefore
conservative group looked to them to
form standard Administration which
indeed finally they have done thank you
thank you I've just put you clear there
the independent Northern District
independent group registered political
party are the leaders in other other
members are a support group and there's
not aligned Independence so there is no
um overall I believe the the numbers of
members that were voted in were
conservative but we've got to a position
where it's a very impact position for
the function of the council we move to
the motion number one members um
I'll put this motion to you obviously
you've had the time to read the motion
um those in favor of accepting this
motion please raise your hands
is that seconded
that's not seconded so
lucky for you tonight then chairman
thank you I am so Tara please uh we've
had a recorded vote requested for motion
number one
okay bear with me one second Tara just
one second sorry counselor suspensely
sorry I would just like to point out
um and using the qualified privilege
that I believe this chamber affords me
um it is my honestly held belief that
prior to the arrangements that were
finally made the modern District support
group was going to do a deal with the
conservative party under a different
leadership and that it does seem to me
it does seem to me that at that time as
I seem to as I recall the situation that
was because there were actually seven
members of that group then we almost had
a situation and I do remember some
conversations with various people
regarding that where I think that group
was quite happy to accept being both the
opposition and in leadership so I do
find this absolutely extraordinary I've
got to say when there have been
negotiations between the opposition
groups to form a cohesive and
Cooperative opposition I do think it's a
shame that we're resorting to such
childish tactics in the chamber tonight
thank you chair sorry I object to that
thank you apologie
you're not getting one okay members I
I'm not I'm not gonna have this okay
we've raised your points Council stamp
you've had your hand up Council fluke
would you please be kind not to be
seated thank you
chairman just for clarity and I'm sorry
but this is already
um been demigrated for what we're
actually supposed to be trying to
achieve for whatever reasons whatever
side of the chamber it's coming from but
can I just ask
um the conservative leader could you
please confirm because obviously there
is a disagreement between two sides here
but you've actually turned around and
said that there was no deal because the
person who was a previous member of the
conservative group had no right to speak
to us so would you be able do you feel
able to actually back that up please
because councilor Durham shaken his head
he was part of it and the words were
frolicking so if we are going to have to
move on and get over it we need to be
telling the truth and I'm not having a
go count suspensely it's this is what
was said at these these meetings and
rather than this Council yet again it's
dirty laundry in public I do think it's
really important that that is stated
whether I'm I'm fibbing which I don't
think I am or well you know we were
approached and by councilor white so can
I have Clarity please and I'd like it
minuteed because this is actually
putting slurs on people's reputations
here Council staff will allow that I'll
allow the one comment to come back and
then we will move on to voting on the
motion that's been levied thank you but
with respect I think I can respond
before we go to the vote thank you you
can do it yeah
uh yes well I'll see what the the
comment was and I think the monetary
officer will understand or recognize it
I say that somebody was off on a Frolic
of their own which is an old legal term
or somebody doing something without the
necessarily Authority that's it thank
you very much councilor fluka finally
thank you yes thank you Jim and look and
I I hope all members say uh and and I
I'm glad that chairman you use your
position to uh inform the leader of the
conservative group that the overall
majority of members is not the
independence because the modern
democratic independent group is the
registered political party and if one
goes to the Electoral commission you'll
see you'll see that they're there and
they've probably got their logo and and
probably their rules and Constitution so
you can't clearly call them independent
they are a political group and they
subscribe to the rules and Constitution
of that party
um chairman I I really don't need to add
any more
um but I find that given some of the
comments during this debate they tend to
fly in the face of what the leader has
said which
mostly I support
all right thank you Council the flu
because the debate on this motion is
completed so we a recorder vote has been
requested Tara would you be pleased to
be kind enough to take the recorded vote
foreign against
against
I can't never heard you uh against Tara
come in Tara against against
four
four against
Captain abstain
he's not here against
[Music]
the Morgan against
staying
against
that's a siddle against
that's a little woman
thank you councilor mix fancy against
I've got to go up four because I
seconded it
against
I seconded it but I'm gonna abstain
the four today
okay so you just want to read those
results out once more Tara
thank you very much Tara so members that
motion fails so we move on to motion two
Council fluke thank you chairman I'm I'm
grateful
um chairman obviously motion uh one has
failed and and I think everybody's noted
that the liberal Democrats and the
conservatives have turned down the
opportunity to be part of the
administration
um so chairman I think in the best
interests of everybody concerned
chairman and bear in mind other motions
that are coming forward tonight uh I
should withdraw motion too thank you
okay is that supported by your seconder
yep thank you
now the members in in that case and
thank you very much indeed uh councilor
fluka I'm going to move to the motion um
table by councilor Norman on um which is
found on page number five which is e
um Council Norman I'd like you to please
put your motion
Morgan my apologies
that's all right Jim I'm normally called
Clive for some reason
um
thank you Clive members councilor Morgan
please uh Mr chairman thank you for
bringing this forward because I think it
hopefully will unwind an anomaly which
has been sort of causing a bit of a
difficulty so far this evening
um
under the terms of the Constitution
following the
um modern independent group coming part
of the administration the monetary
officer uh quite rightly under the terms
of the Constitution advised you at that
meeting that the next largest party
would therefore fought the opposition
which as it was between the liberal Dems
and the laws of support group therefore
there was those two uh leaders would
therefore be leaders of the opposition
which obviously left the conservative
group in somewhat of a different
situation and the horrible assessment or
thought was that we were actually
therefore but I didn't have
part of the part of the actual
Administration which of course we most
certainly are not
therefore
um there was a proposal that there'd be
an amendment to the Constitution to show
that if there's such a situation because
obviously the Constitution I think
didn't envisage the situation we've got
now but where you have a situation where
the largest party is not for the
administration so therefore the leader
of that party should be the leader of
the opposition however these are not
usual times and therefore it has been
agreed the tree but Council drive and
councilor stilts but there should be
three opposition groups in the um
Council in this Municipal here going
forward and therefore I therefore put
put the motion as stated there
that for the remainder of the municipal
year the opposition leadership should be
equally split between the leaders of the
conservative Malden support and liberal
Democrat groups do I have a sector
and councilor stiltzer seconded
thank you thank you Mr Jim thank you
very much indeed councilor Morgan
members of the motion has been put it's
been seconded
um any any member wish to speak on the
motion
no we put the motion to the vote agreed
by sent three by sent yep thank you
members we'll go back to the order paper
excuse me members
I'd like to call on a counselor Council
Stevens with regard to motion D at the
top of page five please I think B is the
next one can I ask why my emotions been
dumped to the bottom have I offended you
no because what it is I've I've turned
the wrong page over
one can imagine that there's several
reams of tree here
so my apologies councilor stamp let's
count to the fluke are there I'd like to
move on to page number four uh motions
from councilor W stamp please thank you
chairman sorry cancer Stevens but
thank you um members um I won't go on
Long Malden District Council is a
statutory duty to promote and maintain
high standards of conduct by its
councilors and co-opted members section
27 little two of the localism ACT 2011
the ACT requires a council to adopt a
code of conduct it is not required in
law for modern District Council to adopt
a joint standards committee but it is
good practice The Joint standards
committee is an ethical committee with
equal political where equal political
balance should apply this was agreed and
adopted by full Council on the 23rd of
June 2020 but due to section 17 of the
local government and Housing Act in 1989
National legislation and the changing
composition of groups is one trigger
automatically requires that the
political balance Provisions reapply
whilst I totally appreciate and
understand that the legislation is
complicated after a long conversation
with our monitoring officer I learned
how complicated chairman the equal
number of seats to all groups applied
with the inclusion of non-aligned
members being offered seats I would like
to propose the following motions
chairman can I read them all and then
would you want to take them what I'd
like to do um cancer stamp if it's okay
I'd like to go through uh individually
because there's different motions need
different voting requirements so if
you'll be good enough to table motion
one and then we'll take motion one and
then we'll vote on that and we'll go
forward from there please can I would
you allow me just to remind members I'm
sure some of you know some of you may be
known forgive me if you feel I'm being a
little bit rude by telling you
um if anybody votes against any of the
motion it fails
so if you vote against it fails if you
abstain am I not allowed to say that
you're absolutely allowed to say but I
just want to cut in I've checked with
the monitoring officer motion motion one
needs a majority motion two needs all
members so just to be clear it's two and
three isn't it Mr monitoring officer
well it depends what two yeah yeah
obviously motion one is self-explanatory
if you vote against two and three the
motion fails
um but I would like to but you can
abstain
laughs thank you yeah you cannot you can
abstain but can I just say the spirit of
this is genuine there is no hidden
agenda this was actually agreed
previously chairman under the previous
administration as well thank you very
much oh I've got to propose motion
motion one please yeah to disband The
Joint standards Committee in its current
form as proposed at the extraordinary
council meeting on the 8th of June 2023.
thank you very much I so propose thank
you very much indeed they've been
proposed and they have been seconded
when the emotions are levied so members
um look at this motion by a show of
hands
please so those in favor of this motion
if you could please raise your hand
to disband so this is to this is in
favor of what the most
should there not be a date a debate uh
well no hands went up um councilor fluka
well I did raise mine did you could you
raise a tad High I seem to be having a
trouble seeing tonight from here I mean
all I was going to say was chairman what
counts the stamp is proposing is is what
was existing before as far as I know and
it seemed to work very very well and now
the you know now that the council is
very much departmentalized amongst
different political groups and
individual uh independent counselors I
think in some ways this makes a biggest
a bit of sense but Tim just to to add
weight uh to the debate I wonder if you
could confirm and I don't want to put
you on the foot put on the uh on the
spot
um so what I'll do is I'll take you off
the spot and I'll say uh Channel Through
you whether or not Mr quelch could
confirm what what the makeup of this
committee is at the moment
if you go to if you go to the
rules the let me just find them
um
yes if you go to rule 15 of the council
procedure rules
you'll see that it says the joint
standards committee shall comprise eight
members of the council political balance
Provisions apply
two persons appointed by the council
upon well that was upon nomination it
says by nomination of the essence
Association of local councils that's
changed now but we do have already two
Parish councilors that have been
appointed to that committee and see the
independent person or reserve non-voting
two Parish councilors are non-voting as
well so it's eight members of this
Council that vote two Parish councilors
that do not and the independent person
or Reserve that do not vote
thank you I'm grateful for that um you
know it's the way this is this these
motions are framed and I'm sure there's
a government's reason why we did them in
this order but motion number three you
know basically said there'll be eight
members with two members taken from each
of the political parties to me that
feels Fair thank you chairman thank you
very much indeed any other member wish
to speak on Motion One
okay so we we need to vote on this
motion members so could I have uh show
our hands to disband The Joint standards
committee's current form as put forward
those in favor please show
okay so it's one two three four five six
seven seven four sorry that's eight yep
sorry I can't see out my left eye it's a
problem eight four thank you those
against please members
one two three four five six
yep confirm that yeah so that's eight
four six against those are to abstain
please
one two three four five six seven and on
abstain says eight says eight extensions
so that's eight for the motion and
that's six against and there's eight
abstentions so that motion passes by
majority
thank you would you like to present my
ocean number two I certainly would
chairman cancel a motion two the council
waves the overall political control of
the authority political balance to
reconstitute the Joint standards
committee
thank you members any members have any
comment on that please
I'd just like to remind members because
no hands have gone up in the chamber
this needs all members to agree well no
no no one voting against no one voting
against yes that's exactly right my
apologies
um yeah do you think we need a recorded
vote because I can't read the mood of
the I can't read the mood of the chamber
we have a recording vote
thank you councilor stem right Tara
thank you very much indeed Tara would
you please take a recorded vote on
motion number two please by cancer stamp
I'm starting the council Passenger
please
I'm staying
abstain
against
failed
I think we don't need to go out for any
further um Tara because the Motions
failed thank you very much and because
thank you Tara members
um if two thousands I'll just check with
the monitor offers there's no basis for
motion three to be put so we won't put
motion three members
but we will put motion four
um together so Council stamp would you
please
um again thank you thank you chair
motion four is that the chair and vice
chair be appointed and there's a slight
Amendment here chairman from the uh it
says buy different political groups I
need to amend that to four different
different political groups and or
non-aligned non-political groups
advice chair to be pointed from
different political groups that means
you can't have two from one party that's
all that means
yep thank you very much the details of
stamp I just need to refer to the
monitoring office for a moment members
so yeah
um yeah please um we now have um a a
rather bizarre situation because the
motion disbanded joint standards
committee
uh disbanded joint standards committee
it stands disbanded
it no longer exists as a committee
and there's nothing further to add
members you've disbanded you've
disbanded The Joint standards committee
chairman does that mean we cannot
misbehave because there's no gents on
joint standards committee absolutely not
I would I would think that the way that
the council needs to to work is in the
way that we all hope it will can I just
make a point as well the the problem
with that motion is that the
constitution
set out you know I'm not sure the
article number talks about
where complaints are made the joint
standards committee has a role in that
if there is a finding in any
investigation that there has been a
breach of the code so members have now
put officers in a very difficult
position
um uh in that we now have confusion
um
so the only way if members if members
are rethinking this that requires
because of the six-month rule it would
require a motion it will require a
motion from 10 members to come in under
rule four if members want a standards
committee because it means that the
constitution Now talks about a standards
committee that no longer there has been
disbanded
yeah thank you chairman I I do you know
I'd I'd composition
expanded
thank you sorry Council sorry Mr
questions
um yeah I must admit I I do despair
slightly because
um you know maybe it should have been
explained uh far more clearly in the
context of motion one and the relation
to motion too but we are where we are
and Mrs Crouch is absolutely right but
look
um this Council doesn't meet again until
September and I hope that everybody goes
away and has a lovely August when we
don't normally have a lot of meetings
and I'm sure that when Council comes
back in September there will be a queue
of people Mr quilts 31 I hope uh saying
that they want to revisit this matter
and and then we can go ahead and I'm I'm
sure that if there is any business on
your desk Mr Welch I'm sure you can
defer until after Council next meets but
I think you know I I pause there because
what I want to say I think fits in
better with motion soon but yeah thank
you yeah
no thank you very much indeed so we are
where we are members
um so we we can't proceed any further
but we will move down onto motions from
councilor siddle
um on page four uh so councilor siddle
please thank you chairman I'm just going
to read the motion because we yeah it's
the same short time uh to prevent the
paralysis of the council business at
four Council meetings and to show that
the council delivers on its Business sa4
Council is the only one Merchant per
political group maybe in accordance with
procedural can be fought forward to the
full council meeting the non-aligned
cancer will also be counted as one group
ISO move thank you very much indeed
Council any member wish to speak on this
councilor Stevens
thank you chair I'd like to propose an
addition to this motion just to add on
the end if agreed this motion is to take
effect from the next full council
meeting thank you
that doesn't substantially yes we can
accept that councilor Stevens thank you
uh Council fluka please yeah thank you
chairman I think anything that the
police democracy I think needs to be
looked at very very carefully but
children we and I'm sure Mr quilch will
will agree with me but we seem to have
lost our way somewhat with motions
coming to council because
for the benefit of new members and those
that might not have read the procedural
basically all motions stand referred to
the main committees for a decision it
was I think it was only because of the
uh a very clever word Smith who asked
that Council decided emotion and that it
shouldn't be referred that that seems to
have become the default position and
it's not and the whole purpose of
bringing forward motions is it
accelerates the process now if if
somebody or one political group comes up
with a really good idea through emotion
and it's to do with strategy and
resources the chairman has the right to
send it straight to that Community or PJ
PG a or if it's a motion to do with
something else it could be it could be
the overview and scrutiny committee but
you know motions do provide a really
good conduit for members to bring things
forward and and with three opposition
parties I think that's really good I
think to restrict it in any way is not
good because you could get to the stage
where only one motion comes forward but
that particular party wants to bring
forward a second one all motions uh
members are basically the chairman if if
they're not compliant and they don't
comply with governance then the chairman
can actually reject them and and I think
uh his power veto probably goes a little
bit further as well so you know I would
be very much against this but
before
well if I've said something funny
counselor uh councilors then please let
me know what it is
um but yeah I would be very much against
this but I do think there's a compromise
here and uh in uh April
um
um misuse facilitated a meeting and
you'll have to forgive me because no one
can remember what it was we don't know
Mr Dodson might know just casual just
remember you have three minutes yeah and
I put into my clock I've got one minute
and 10 seconds left so I'll be very
quick so we can't remember if it was
strategy and resources working group or
the corporate governance working for it
and we actually spoke about motions and
where we've gone wrong with motions is
is that okay there will always be that
time when they come in on a Tuesday
morning before 12 o'clock or whenever it
is but if members bring forward motions
early then committee services or whoever
can pick them up with members and see
where they want to go and it may well be
that officers might want to bring
forward a report which is how these
things have always worked in the past so
chairman I I think that that piece of
work by Miss Hughes needs to be picked
up on
um yeah I agree with you we don't want
to log Jam this council with the night
and I've been a great exponent of that
in the past but I think in this
particular case and I hope you agree
with me leader that I think this needs
looking at I'd don't think we should
make a decision about one per group
tonight but I think we should
follow the default foil route which is
the default position in in our in our
rules of procedure and and refer this
for a proper discussion to the corporate
governance working group I say and then
we can talk about how we manage
emotions going forward because you know
maybe we should get to the stage where
we shouldn't have this last minute rule
it should be a bit earlier so chairman
the the um the default position under
the rule says that they should be
deferred and there's no reason why this
can't be deferred and be dealt with by
that working group before the next
meeting Council and then that way
Council and Spencer will get a wish
probably that it will be instigated at
that uh sorry I beg you for enough
Stevens I beg it on
um it's uh it would then be dealt with
then but that is that is the default
position six seconds
I've got six seconds now you finish
within six seconds which is remarkable
thank you very much yeah I just cancel
the Darren please
yeah thank you
um chairman for the benefit of new
members this is a relatively new
phenomenon because as counselor thinker
it's quite right I I think for about 10
years as a member of this Authority
there weren't any emotions I don't
recall a single motion
in the sort of 10 years
until very recently and it seems to have
completely got out of hand in that we're
now we never had a situation where full
Council meetings had to be stopped due
to timing
um and there are two reasons for that
one is the propensity of recorded votes
which in many cases are a complete waste
of time not always but in many cases and
the number of motions so if members are
going to continue to put motions to full
Council the only way to stop the gross
waste of everybody's time is to restrict
them so that they are
the most valid motions um are agreed and
cancer treatment is absolutely right we
are a committee not a cabinet and the
majority of decisions are taken at
committee
so there isn't or there shouldn't be a
necessity to bring all of these motions
in fact any motions particularly to full
Council thank you councilor Durham any
other member wish to speak on this one
uh sorry councilman thank you uh thank
you thank you chair and from my
understanding this is this is quite
clear
um and I think quite Democratic the each
political party could bring forward a
motion so you could Lobby I presume
another party if you have two motions
and ask them to bring that motion on for
you
so in that way we are I think being
quite Democratic with this motion and I
do think we are in a situation where
Council meetings are being locked jammed
and we are wasting so much time and I
think this can be dealt with right here
and now and I think it's quite clear and
I think we should deal with it so we can
move on with the business
thank you thank you councilor passenger
councilor Stan please yeah I'm always
banging on about democracy and you're
taking it away from elected members I'm
sure the motion will fail and it's the
wrong motion that's going to fail my ad
um but I certainly won't be supporting
it because this is something could
happen at any stage to any one of us and
so we only have so many Council meetings
a year and I I certainly don't I don't
like being hogtied or hand-tied whatever
the saying is by anybody
um which I think is quite obvious
um so I'm afraid I won't be supporting
this motion because I think you're
actually removing our rights as elected
members and what I would say is that me
standing here I got the most folks out
of everybody sit in this chamber from
all and sort of in preparation in
proportion of the voting as well so I
would like to say I want to speak on
behalf of my 927 who voted for me who
would not like us to be restricted at a
full council meeting because people
watch this I know I've got people within
Burnham watching this tonight because I
want to see how some of these motions
are going they're not raised on a whim
chairman yes some people may think they
are I've watched and listened tonight
when councilor flucas speaks as soon as
he speaks you've got the no you can see
it's going to be voted against you've
got the the body language that humming
and are in the the whatever we didn't
you're all right did you want to speak
because the thing is
no the thing is we didn't give any
facial or Fed Up Expressions when the
leader sat and spoke for 10 minutes or
15 minutes
please share the respect you talk about
us not being respectful as our little
group over here you shouldn't be
disrespectful some just because you
don't like somebody they can speak a lot
of sense thank you thank you give
councilor stamp accounts
I will stand up because I'm sure
um
yeah I agree with Council Durham and
councilor passenger I just want to say
slightly different point something like
councilor Durham I've completed 12 years
here I don't recall a motion to council
and it has to be said Council both
members and officers are infinitely
better served by our report to council
and not the Russian verbal update that
the officers has to have to produce on
the night and we have to listen and take
frantic notes we're all infinitely
better served by a well-written report
that we can read and have in front of us
and we wouldn't be in this position if
we hadn't you know had extra parts of
meetings added in the afternoon for 15
motions that were probably withdrawn and
we all went home with nothing to do for
the next four hours we're only in this
position because
it's been in my view and misused I'm
afraid it's misused so so many motions
have been brought that again in my view
their nonsense or they should have been
brought previously for instance one
changing the schedule of meetings if we
wanted to introduce extra meetings of
committees we should have done it when
we were growing the schedule not a
couple of months later
I I fully support the motion thank you
thank you councilor Thompson and Council
passenger wanted to come back
thank you uh chairman you just uh let
everybody know there are 10 people
watching this meeting tonight
uh so in terms of this you know the
other members have have backed up what I
was going to say as a preamble you know
this is to control the business of
council as we can see now we haven't got
to the business of council and it's
quarter to nine yeah so that just
reinforces why I brought forward this
motion thank you
thank you councilors and Council
passenger thank you chair and just going
back to councilor steps counselors
counselor stamps reference to democracy
these motions are actually stopping
democracy we are here to deal with the
business of the people who voted for us
you may have more votes than anyone else
but we were all elected and the
residents expect us to deal with the
business that we're supposed to be
dealing with these motions stop the
business because we run out of time and
we have to all rush through very
important documents have been written by
officers we rush through those because
we have to leave the chamber because by
10 o'clock we all need to go home so
democracy is being blocked by these
continual motions
thank you thank you very much indeed
what's the excuse me it's it's my
chamber at the moment thank you your
point of order has been called I have to
hear the point of order thanks German
procedure rule three or four because all
of these motions has tabled perhaps with
the exception of mine and counselor
Morgans
um should all be by default referred it
have all say quite clearly that they are
referred to the appropriate committee so
we could have done that three quarters
of an hour ago and then the appropriate
committee can look at it and say no
thank you and and we've just gone to
that's what our rules say none of these
motions with the exception I think of
the two I mentioned should even be here
and in fact you know if we're going to
do anything else other than not to refer
these motions then you know we're we're
acting contrary to our own rules okay
thank you Council I have um I have a
comment to make and it is regarding the
Motions I I have a leaning that again it
is um emotion use of emotions is a good
thing for members in the Constitution I
think we have we have to look at
ourselves in the mirror when we when we
raise emotion I also disagree that the
non-aligned councils will be counted as
a group because the definition of
non-aligned is exactly that so I think
we've been disingenuous to those members
but we've had a debate we've had the
motion put the council system spoken
twice on the motion so I'm going to put
this motion to the vote members okay so
those members in favor of this motion
please raise your hands
that's one two three four
five six seven eight nine ten eleven
twelve thirteen fourteen
fifteen
do you have your hand up Council Stevens
no okay 15. so it's 50 it's 15 in favor
those against please
that's one two three four five six six
six against six again thank you very
much and those abstains
cancer Stevens and myself abstain so
that motion is passed and Carrie Tara
thank you that puts us in a very
difficult position because the wording
wasn't changed going forward
Gemini chairman I think we take it as
read that it starts to me one thank you
very much
I stand correct well I sit corrected so
we will then change
did you add that cancer Stevens
sorry what am I being asked did you add
that this scope for this motion going
forward yes that's from tonight
I the piece I read out is if agreed this
motion is to take effect from the next
full council meeting and my
understanding was that you'd said yes
that's the case from The Next Episode
and you said that that was accepted yeah
yeah the next four Council yes the next
one starts from there yeah it starts
from the next one so we will go for
motion number two Council please okay so
make your second motion goes straight to
the motion again because of time despite
the recommendation the recent members
remuneration
about allowances for special
responsibility it did not reflect the
work and responsibilities of the vice
chair of the council and the vice chair
of overview and scrutiny and this motion
recommends that the special answer for
these positions are brought into line
with other Vice chairman bemidji's and
they are set at 25 of the Basic Land so
I so move
thank you
anybody wish to speak on this yeah
Council stamp
oh okay yeah I do actually want to speak
I thought we'd already agreed this
previously to the um I can't remember
which meeting I couldn't find it when we
talked yes we did Chairman we actually
discussed this at one of the strategy
resources or one of the meetings about
these allowances Council Spencer Lee
spoke very eloquently and passionately
because she had every right to she
worked really hard on the ons and I've
no disrespect to councilor Morgan I was
hoping she was going to get chair of
those days because she worked she did
her Stripes as I call it last time and I
think she should have been elected as
the chair of that committee but I don't
we are actually talking about giving our
taxpayers money yet again to cancer are
you all right yeah cancel his allowances
are gonna go up again yeah they already
went up substantially because of the
remuneration panel or whatever it was
when it was agreed last time so you know
we're talking about struggling
financially but we're talking about
giving our councilors more money
and I don't agree with
I mean I've already said that I'm going
to give my uplift my allowance to local
charities and I urge other people to do
so
um Gemini I I agree very much what
councilor stamp says you know this
council is not Amazon you don't put in
an order and get it the next day you
know we've agreed something now we're
going back on it I mean what on Earth
happened to civic pride and civic duty
you know I I but you know we all serve
on Parish councils we don't get paid but
you know chairman again there's other
issues around this and and the whole
issue around how we manage these
allowances I mean maybe we should take a
a leaf out of Braintree Braintree
Borough Council uh they have a rule if
you don't turn up you don't get your um
announce that that month and I know that
the chairman of the program committees
as I'd call them the main committees on
the sixth week cycle of meetings uh they
get paid 920 pounds for a meeting and
perhaps an agenda amazing to me uh
that seems like a lot of money but the
remuneration panel didn't want to meet
with me so that that was never put to
them but it does seem like a lot of
money
um and and I know that the vice
Chairman's not here tonight chairman so
long since I've seen him maybe we should
put pictures of Vice chairman
thank you Council for the councilor um
Paula spensely please
the moment I occupy the um role
obviously this is about the role and not
the person but as it happens I do occupy
the role of Vice chair of ominous and I
did last year and I would ask that um we
don't consider this now and put it off
till next year as I'm quite happy to
work for absolutely nothing like I have
done I've got 100 record of attendance
at public meetings since I started and
and last year I chaired on this quite a
bit as well and I'm quite happy to to
carry on like I'm even though I have to
say I'm as poor as a church mouse if we
can put that officially on record it's
absolutely fine and um I I think maybe
bring that forward again next year for
another person or when I leave the role
thank you thank you very much councilor
we've heard the division Champions oh
sorry Maddie I'm at Council Thompson
apologist chair so I'm still short
I was a bit slow to do that well I would
like to applaud councilor Paula Spencer
on her attitude I think that's very good
and generous and very Civic minded of
her but
the idea of allowances is that everyone
and all residents get a fair crack and
that this role isn't left to people who
don't have to work don't need the money
don't have to give up work in order to
do it which are used after I don't know
um but in any case I think for equal
work there ought to be an equal time
spent on things there ought to be equal
allowances and I'd be happy if someone
brought forward emotions you know put it
what we currently have or even a bit
less and then share it out fairly but I
do think what's wrong is that the vice
chairman of the committee that does the
amount of work that o s does should have
the same as other Vice chairman because
as councilor Paul Spencer pointed out
you know they do often have to share
there are often meetings in between
officer meetings outside bodies
especially the program committees it
isn't just a matter of how well the
meeting takes three hours so that's
that's what the allowance is worth so
and I do have some faith in the
remuneration panel it meant about 12
years ago when I was a Jewish member and
I I was interviewed then and I think
they do deal with these things fairly so
I
sorry I've got councilor Fluker is
distracting me and right ADHD makes that
quite difficult to concentrate on
um
so yeah I support motion as it stands
and if someone comes up with a better
idea I should support that later okay I
think Council Thompson members we've had
this the motion stands I've got to put
the motion to the vote those in favor
can you please raise your hands
nice and high if you one two three four
those against please
one two three four four against thank
you and those abstaining
one two three and myself that'll be four
so that margin is carried thank you very
much indeed members we now move on to
the motion which I miscalculated earlier
on in the agenda paper which is actually
counselor from councilor Stevens please
thank you chair I'll just read the
motion out at short and sweet to
prioritize essential business at full
Council meetings motions at each full
council meeting shall be debated at the
end of the public part of the meeting
and subject to time
thank you very much indeed Council
Stevens councilor Neil
thank you chair I'd just like some
clarity actually obviously it states
within the uh the motion that all
motions will be debated after oh sorry
at the end of the public meeting
can we just confirm when that is in the
agenda is that in PNC is that after the
public have been able to make their
questions or is it just before the the
Chairman's asked to do important urgent
items thank you that would be before if
there's any business that they need to
be conducted in private yeah
thank you Council fluka thank you
chairman you know the whole idea the
whole idea the Motions could apply
in relation to items that are going to
be considered as part of business that
evening so we could find ourselves in a
really difficult decision whereby we
could make a decision and then at the
end of the meeting a a motion could come
forward
um a motion could come forward that that
could Nate what's been decided I mean
chairman we've we've now agreed that I
don't know if we've agreed that we're
going to have a maximum of five motions
or seven motions a council
um because I listen carefully it wasn't
clear but if we follow the rules I don't
see any reason why we can't just have
them in normal plays and and perhaps
chairman we'd be more Vigilant in
applying all four and you have the right
to refer these straight to committees
black and white and rules thank you
thank you very much Council Thompson and
then councilor siddle
um yeah
I believe and Mr quilt you might need to
convert that sits within the gift of the
chairman to move items up and down the
agenda anyway so yeah if the chairman
feels that on a particular evening
motions can wait till the end of the
gender because they don't apply to
business during the evening then I would
have thought we'd be happy with that and
and for that reason only actually I
won't support it because I think that
the chairman should be able to deal with
them on the way through if need be thank
you thank you thank you
Castle settle please
uh yeah cancer fluke has really given
the reason why to move them at the end
of the meeting uh because if it is on
the business of the agenda then the
recommendation at that particular time
could get amended to any motion that's
come forward so we would do the council
business first and then and therefore if
if that needs to be reflected in some
way we could alter any recommendation as
that part of the business meeting
um and therefore at the end the motion
won't be necessary so it would make
things much more efficient and effective
if we move these motions to the end
thank you very much indeed Council
settle members I
um believe we've no more hands up so
what I need to do is is for this motion
could I have a show of hands for the
motion please
so again one two
three four five five four those against
please
one two three
10 11 12 13 14 myself
any of those two abstain please
so it's one abstention so thank you so
that motion fails so thank you very much
indeed members we now move on to agenda
item 12 which is questions in accordance
with procedural six three of which
notices have been given I can confirm
there has been none
we move on to agenda item 13 which is a
report appointments to committee this
agenda item is found on pages 103 to 108
of the agenda pack and I call on Mr
Dodson to present the report please
thank you chairman
um there were a number of positions in
committees that weren't appointed to by
council at the the previous meeting so
this report seeks to give members the
opportunity to to make those
appointments
um I don't normally refer to the the
recommendations in the introduction but
I think it's
it's required on this occasion so
recommendation one that the council
appoints a non-aligned member to the
overview and scrutiny committee for the
municipal year
um needs to be undertaken
um
recommendation two I believe will need
to be deferred yes chairman thank you
um
recommendation three
um refers to the the allocation to be
advised by the program's performance and
governance manager who has advised
and if you bear with me one second I
will pass on
that advice
so the
the
recommendation three that two members
are appointed to appointments board for
a municipal year 2023-24.
um the reason for the recommendation is
that one seat is allocated to the leader
of the opposition and then two other
members politically balanced
um to be politically balanced one seat
would be liberal Democrat one would be
District support group and one
conservative in light of these three
groups providing an opposition leader
further to the motion earlier tonight
it's now suggested that the three
opposition leaders are allocated to the
remaining seats which would then give
the political balance
and then under recommendation for is
that the councilor swindles appointed to
the vacant liberal democracy on the
licensing committee for the municipal
year
23-24. thank you very much godson
members any any comments councilor still
please thank you Mr chairman I'd
actually like to give up my seat on the
appointments build and actually nominate
a member of my group
yep just gone through with it you've
picked up the advice of the monitoring
office so thank you Council fluka Jim I
I mean if if you're saying that's not
right then then recommendation two just
speaks to two members are appointed to
the appointment's board it doesn't
mention and I think Mr quiltsch has
woven in the uh the leaders of the
opposition everything else that two
members are appointed to the
appointments Paul for the municipal year
political group allocation to be advised
um it means one would have to change the
the recommendation to bring forward what
you've just suggested in relation to and
and the other thing chairman about this
is you know we would we could find that
one of these groups and they they may
well because I don't know everybody in
this chamber there may be a terrific HR
person who is not who is not a deputy
leader of a group and that could be
really useful you know to have somebody
on there you know I've been on these
committees for many years and you know
and it really is important to you know
have the right sets and skills on these
meetings so you know if counselor I
believe that
um actually recommendation Roman 3 uh
actually basically it says we can
appoint whoever we do I I appreciate it
makes sense maybe to have the deputy
leaders or the leaders of the opposition
or whatever but if that's not the case
uh and I don't know who this counselor
stilts wants to send but I'm not even
sure we can send uh well I don't think
so you can send a substitute even again
one needs to think these things through
I think some things Jim before we get to
this stage I'll just refer to the
monitoring office just give us a moment
please members
let me see
appointments board
appointments for two members to serve
should I read it out yeah I think so
help members understanding
um again rule 15 of the procedure rules
says the appointments board is to be two
members to serve in addition to the
leader or Deputy leader opposition
leader or deputy and chairpersonal vice
chair person of strategy and resources
and performance governance and audit
Community well as we now have three
opposition leaders
I think as Mr Dodson has already
explained in order to make and that fits
in with political balance as well there
is now no scope for two other floating
members as it were because all are a
sign based on their designations their
special positions because we now have
three opposition leaders not one
and also the board has to be politically
balanced as well those three opposition
leaders actually ensure there is
political balance as I understand it
is focused
um
I mean you know we're going to go
through this thing later on tonight with
the finance board there has to be a
willingness on members to sit on the you
know we can't say to people just because
you hold this position you've got to be
on that committee there has to be a
willingness and and if that willingness
isn't there for whatever reason from
from one of the leaders of the
opposition
um then there has to be something in
place to allow it and I I think the
fullback position Mr quilt
yeah I just sort of think that the
fallback position is these you know you
could apply this two-member thing and
still include you know I don't know if
the if the leader of of these other
parties want to sit on this appointments
board or not but you know we we can't
just cut it off if somebody says they
don't want to sit on it
thank you Council thank you yeah um the
rule 15 says
um it's opposition leader or deputy
so so so the point would be the point
would be bearing in mind the
Constitution
um that there is obviously two options
there there is the opposition leader if
the opposition leader either doesn't
want to sit or can't sit then the deputy
would sit in the opposition Leader's
place now can I just say a point here
it's really important that in my view as
monitoring offers are important that if
members take on the position of being
the leader of a group and that makes
them opposition leader then they're
actually saying that they're prepared to
take on the responsibilities that the
constitution says are linked to that
position and I think it's important that
members understand that so if a member
doesn't want to do it there's a question
mark over
really have they
should they be in that position bearing
in mind what the Constitution says
this is and can I just say this isn't my
Constitution chairman this is the
council's Constitution I'm just telling
you what your Constitution says and I'm
giving you the implications of that as
well
thank you Mr quotes Castle settle please
yeah thank you it's the appointments
board is is uh when we recruit a
strategic high level position
and because we are recruiting for a high
level strategic position which means
that the leaders will be working with
that person it's really important I
think that the leaders are represented
on that appointments board otherwise it
makes a nonsense as Mr quality is saying
of being a leader and being on that
board and the whole point of this is as
a leader you are taking a strategic
position and you will be interviewing
someone else's position like Mr Lucas
who is the last person to be interviewed
so we need to that's why it needs to
reflect that composition
thank you very much Nick Council said
well I think I think I think Mr Dawson's
already said yeah it's got to be
politically balanced and so those two
members are now the two additional
opposition leaders that we have rather
than while we have three yeah so there
is no longer two floating members yeah
okay thank you so members in the
experience of business tonight so we
still have some very important
businesses to transact I'm going to go
to the recommendations
a little one that the council appoints a
non-aligned members of the overview and
security committee for the municipal
year
2023-2024 can I have that by Cent
members agree thank you very much
very good point so we've agreed to do
that of the not aligned who is
nominating for the position Council
Norman that's the only person Council
Norman
sorry I couldn't quite a good yeah it
says councilor siddle Norman thank you
very much indeed
just bear with me and that's lovely
okay we're gonna defer little two
um three I think we've just discussed
and reached an agreement that it is the
leaders or the deputies of the
opposition and we have a simple decision
to make on level four the council NJ
Swindle is appointed to the vehicle
Libra Democrat seat on the licensing
committee for the mystery year 2023 2024
so I have that by uh Ascent please
members agreed thank you very much
indeed yeah I mean I don't think you've
agreed through You by a sense
excuse me
did I not agree that boy did my
apologies members is that agreed by a
sin thank you
very kind of you
okay we move on to a gender item 14
which is an adjournment of the meeting
which is no we don't need we adjourn the
meeting at 9 10 and we recommenced the
meeting at 9 10 13 seconds thank you
members so we don't need that
don't need that okay now we we go to
agenda item 15 which is a report from
the local government Association which
is found on 16 my apologies which are
found on pages 109 to 148 and I'll ask
councilor siddle to stand to raise some
information please thank you very much
Simon the LGA provides the opportunity
uh for a peer review of member councils
to be undertaken once every five years
at no additional cost
uh to the council the council requested
through the previous uh section 151
officer that a financial peer challenge
be undertaken in the last Financial year
the review is about identifying areas of
possible Improvement within the council
and implementing best practice across
the council
the initial findings of the peer
challenge were reported back to members
via presentation of the peer review on
the 1st of March 2023 and a repeat
briefing was provided for members
earlier this week
a detailed report was produced by the
peers and this will be published on the
website with the recommendations now
responded to by officers via draft
action plan
as I mentioned earlier in my statement
we well we're holding a top team away
date in August to agree priorities and
to ensure Financial stability which is
one of the recommendations
as a recommendation sat out it is
proposed that there will be a new
Finance working group which will
represent all political groups at the
council as well as a non-aligned
representation
we need to ensure that there is
alignment of the mtfs to the corporate
plan and other Council strategies as
this will improve how the council
operates
this will mean a golden thread from
strategies to services and
implementation of objectives is
financially sound
if we adopt these approaches it will
strengthen the financial processes of
the council and work towards our
corporate plan objective of smarter
finances so I'm just going to go through
the recommendations and that is little
one that the contents of the finance
peer challenge report appendix 1 be
noted that the council's response to the
six key recommendations set out in the
draft Financial peer challenge action
plan appendix to be approved that's
subject to little two being approved to
delegate approval of the council's
response to the other recommendations
set out on the draft Financial peer
challenge action plan at appendix 2 to
the finance member group that's subject
to little two being approved to approve
the revised terms of reference for the
finance member group
set out at appendix 3 as detailed in the
response to recommendation five of the
draft Financial peer challenge action
plan that's subject to little two being
approved to approve the revised
membership of the finance member group
as detailed in the response to
recommendation 5 of the draft Financial
peer challenge action plan at appendix 2
and appendix four I say move do I have a
second
second bit
I'd now like to hand over to Miss Ms
Lucas
thank you thank you chair
um
so I think the the leaders um set out
um most of the key things
um that I wanted to cover but just to
add
that
um a little bit of context around the
finance peer review itself
um I set out at paragraph 3.2 of the
report um I just wanted members to note
that
um The Challenge itself is not an
inspection
um it's it is to use the expertise and
knowledge of of peer um peer authorities
to
um to and use that information to help
improve the financial processes and
practices of of the council so as part
of the process
um the peer team spent two and a half
days at the council and spoke to more
than 25 people and they considered five
themes which were set out at paragraph
3.4 of the report which covered
Financial leadership Financial strategy
planning and forecasting decision making
across the council Financial outcomes
and partnership and innovation
thank you
so I would just like to quickly cover
the um six key recommendations that were
made as part of the finance peer
challenge
and they are set out at paragraph 3.6 of
the reports
so the the seek the six key
recommendations were one
um to further develop the medium-term
financial strategy by linking it to
other strategies and plans and to
include sensitivity sensitivity analysis
as soon as reasonably practical
um secondly to arrange a top team away
day for officers and members
post-election to agree the priorities
and to ensure Financial stability
stability
thirdly they recommended that there
should be that we should provide
mentoring support to our senior leaders
both members and officers
fourthly to have more clarification of
the roles for both members and for
officers
the fifth recommendation was to
establish a corporate finance board
which would own the corporate plan and
finance for the authority
and the sixth key recommendation was
that all staff members should
acknowledge the urgency of the financial
position and Urgent action should be
taken to develop a realistic and robust
plan to deliver the required
efficiencies and savings to ensure
ongoing Financial sustainability
so the council's key
um sorry the council's response to those
key recommendations is set out in the
action plan at appendix 2. in addition
there's another 30 recommendations
um which are not being asked to be
um sort of voted on this evening but
instead to be referred to the finance
member group for their consideration and
response and for that group to also
monitor the implementation of those key
actions
um so the lead has already made
reference to recommendation five of the
report which is to have the proposed
um a new proposed terms of reference for
the finance member group and that set
out at appendix 3 and that would fulfill
the function of the corporate finance
board which was suggested by the peer
reviews
and the finance member group would be
responsible for oversight of the mtfs
and saving strategy for the authority
and for making clear recommendations for
approval to the strategy and resources
committee and or the council
um and the last point I would just like
to bring members attention to is that
the um recommendation to approve a
revised membership of the finance member
group
um which was that it should be comprised
of all political group leaders plus the
chairman and vice chairperson of the
strategy and resources committee and the
performance governance and audit
committee and the purpose of that
recommendation is to ensure that there
is a no Silo approach across the council
so that clear recommendations can be
made for the council's consideration
so I think that's all I'd like to say at
this point Thank you thank you very much
today miss Lucas thank you members I
open the chamber councilor Paula
spensely please
okay so I'd like to speak to little five
please because I think given the current
um
constitution of the council in terms of
the different groups
that it would be appropriate for us to
have political balance within this
within the finance board and obviously
at the moment that won't be achieved
just by having the chairs so I suggest
that the chair positions remain in it
but that we appoint in a way to ensure
political balance with extra members and
also that we need to allow for
substitutions where possible because I
do take the point that while you take on
the leadership role of a group you take
on responsibility for all things but we
might have people within particular
groups who would be
better at finance and that would then be
for each group to decide whether they
want their chair presumably if a group's
put forward a chair for SNR that's the
person to be doing that but I think that
you know I'd like to amend the proposal
at five to include political balance and
also um to allow for substitution thank
you okay well we're going to go through
five seconds we're going to go through
the individual recommendations on a one
by one basis just to let members know
councilor stamp
um yeah thank you Mr chairman can I ask
for the monsoon officer to explain why
we're looking at changing the finance
working group when it was only just
appointed last month please I think it's
important that all members understand
that you most probably you have decided
that you don't have to adhere to that
six-month Rule and I think it's
important we all understand why
yeah okay
um we're back to the procedure rules
and
um
rule 12 versus this is what councilor
stamp is referring to rescission of
preceding resolution which says no
motion to rescind any resolution passed
within the preceding six months no
motion or Amendment to the same effect
as one which has been rejected within
the preceding six months shall be
proposed unless the notice the notice
thereof given in pursuance of rule four
Bears the name of at least 10 members of
the council in other words in other
words
I interpret that to mean
that uh where there is an attempt to
rescind or amend
a a decision of counsel within the
six-month period under rule four
it requires 10 members rather than two
however the report of the officer is
made under rule five if you go to rule
five
rule five says there can be
um dealing with the issue of motions and
amendments which may be made without
notice and if you go down to sub rule
six adoption of recommendations by
officers
so because rule 12 talks about if there
is to be notice under rule for that
requires within the six month bill that
requires 10 members but this is a report
this report is from an officer and it's
pursuant to rule five
sorry I know I do understand because
we've had a conversation but how can you
keep changing the rules to suit whatever
agenda you want to put on or bring a
paper we've all been told that there is
you just said you have to have 10
members which I think Council still
brought on one of his motions earlier so
now you're changing it for an officer
report I'm I'm actually genuinely
concerned not concerned confused
I I I'm reading I read out to you what
rule 12 said I haven't changed rule 12
it's always been like that for as long
as I can remember
since I came back to the council in 2017
I have merely read out to you what it
says and my understanding that and
members can read it themselves and if
you the chairman disagrees with me then
he can rule he has the final word
but I read that out to you and it talks
about rule four uh notice under rule
four has to be by ten not by two because
normally it's two
this is under rule five sub rule six
so that doesn't apply rule 12 doesn't
apply
that's my understanding of the rules the
chairman has the final ruling on it
thank you Mr gross that is what the
Constitution says councilor fluka yeah
thank you chairman look you know I've no
Mr Welch long enough to know that he
wouldn't say what he just said unless he
was confident he was right and I and I I
can also put memes in their comfort zone
because I can remember an exchange with
councilor Boyce who I'm pleased to say
has been moved to uh Saint Peter's
Hospital today
um and and he he admitted uh that's the
wrong word accepted that maybe he'd
misinterpreted something but I believe
your interpretation is correct
um very quickly first can I pay tribute
to our 4151 officer who over the last
couple of years I spoke to on several
occasions with regards to a lot of the
issues raised in this report and in
particular the discounted items raised
in the three schedules the savings that
were presented to us last year I didn't
I urge all the new members to look at
those overall chairman I don't recognize
anything new in this report and some of
the issues highlighted have been obvious
and being discussed for some time
particularly so the drawdown of reserves
it does nevertheless provide us with a
much needed wake-up call to where we
really are I'd also thank the LGA peer
Dawn Garten the DCS at Melton Bower
Council for her professional input into
the report and recognize the excellent
work that she's done on her own mtfs at
her own Council and I hope that as part
of this ongoing review she agrees to
visit us again to share her wealth of
experience
um chairman now turned to report page
110 paragraph 3.6
um number one chairman I've asked before
but does this mean we're now going to
get a fully costed corporate plan in a
course accordance with the motion agreed
by Council little two can you confirm
that if if this is to happen and and
from what the leader said earlier this
meeting is going to go ahead this this
away day is going to go ahead
um but chairman it needs to happen
straight away I think there was
reference to the end of August or
whatever it needs to happen straight
away chairman because in but when
Council meets next time we'll be five
months nearly halfway through the
municipal year and if we take the advice
in the report
that will be around one month from when
we should be starting our own budget
setting so in my mind this working group
or or whatever
um needs to start meeting immediately
um little five
um I'm listening to what officers have
said this has been referred to as a
group a working group and a board
um so if it's a working group well can
you confirm what it is because if it's a
working group you can send substitutes
and in number six
um chairman to me that could mean
providing for minimal savings uh or cost
neutral budget something some members
have been banging on about for the last
two years to the point that some of them
are getting quite stoked over the issue
um chairman with the proposed bold
straight working group membership we are
lucky enough we really are lucky enough
to have some highly qualified Innovative
experienced and committed members and
that said and to give them a clear
directive from Council I propose adding
another recommendation chairman that in
the best interests of value for
residents businesses and customers and
the protection of our residence cash
reserves because that that's what they
are they're not out they're out
residents cash reserves the finance
board working group
delivers a cost-neutral budget for the
municipal year 24.25 I believe that can
be done
and and I believe reading the LGA report
they believe that we can move very close
to doing that I believe that could be
done chairman that is my proposal is an
addition uh as an additional
recommendation to stop hemorrhaging
money basically
thank you very much
uh thank you chair uh yeah it is quite
interesting that uh in 2019 when the
previous corporate plan was produced
there was no costing whatsoever with
that you know so we are doing much more
than being done in the past uh the away
day will be happening either on the 9th
or the 16th of August I've been pressing
the LG APS to come back on that once we
set up the finance working group it can
meet as immediately as as the people are
available to it
um interestingly that uh Council Fluker
commends Dawn at the officer from Melton
uh they have a corporate plan with less
detail than ours and no cost at all in
it so yeah it's it's good that yeah we
are doing more than the peer already
that is recommended
um in terms of that situation
[Laughter]
um
so in terms of our budget report we are
setting out the finance and service
plans and how that is overseen
operationally by directors so we are we
are implementing that and and yeah part
of the finance group that we will set up
will look at those things that councilor
fluka is proposing and the sooner we set
it up the better I agree
thank you very much make an amendment
and I'm delighted that Council agreed to
it uh I would like to have Casa Durham
please
thank you very much
um chairman
um
I've read the report and I watched the
recording of the briefing the other
night
um and it's quite clear that the LGA
peers spent a long time producing this
report and went into quite a lot of
detail
um I have a mixed experience of LGA
peers I think it's fairly reasonable to
say as councilor Philippa and councilor
Thompson will uh testify
because they have been known in the past
to carry out an in-depth peer review and
then when one of the lead members didn't
like the conclusion
believe it or not they changed their res
they changed their recommendations more
or less immediately
um which was bizarre in the extreme so I
have
reservations uh about the LGA uh
although I'm actually on the LGA peer
list anyway but uh but I do have my my
doubts are based on previous experience
I'd like to take this opportunity to
um highlight the commercial income or
lack of commercial income
for this uh uh to to help with our
budget deficit and I want to take issues
slightly I'm afraid with the leader's
comment that nothing had been done in
the past
councilor fluke will recall because he
was ably my Deputy in 2017 when I stood
at the front there where the leader
stood tonight
and I said to members at that time
we are going to face financial
difficulties unless we get a commercial
strategy we looked very hard we had some
very exciting projects we looked at a
cinema and other facilities on the prom
we looked at building a crematorium we
formed a crematorium working group and
now we've missed out us has been said
because a commercial operation uh is
building one in wood and Mortimer every
single commercial idea that we put
forward unfortunately the members at
that time said oh dear we haven't got
the expertise we're too risk-averse we
don't want to take the risk and uh
unfortunately
I think partly because those members at
the time did not appreciate the
financial difficulties that we were in
didn't agree to pursue any of the
commercial projects so it is grossly
unfair to accuse previous
administrations of not pursuing a
commercial policy because we would have
done had the memberships uh then
supported it and we would no doubt as is
being proved by the crematorium probably
being a much better financial position
now have we been allowed to do it but
um as I said I I look at this LGA
recommendation I support it with the
caveat that uh
well I I support it with trepidation and
some nervousness thank you thank you
councilor Durham councilor Nick Spencer
please thank you chair
um
so this is this is very new to me but I
do have a sense of deja vu because
having served on two different governing
bodies in two different sectors over the
last seven years I've been a recipient
of peer reviews and um uh reports on
turning around finances so I'd just like
to comment briefly on a few of the
recommendations so recommendation six uh
the reviewers talk about efficiencies
and savings
um and as Council fluka has rightly said
we need to move urgently on that the
response is a savings strategy my fear
is that the efficiencies side of things
will be overlooked and and if you look
at the reports as a whole it's about
smarter working it's about a finance
team who are well trained and resilient
and flexible it's it's about
accountability there's a lot of issues
about culture and the way that we work
that are in there and one of the dangers
I've seen with saving strategies that
you look at the imminent crisis and get
very operational and look at oh we'll
cut this line we'll take 10 000 off that
and five thousand off this and lose the
bigger picture so I won't go on about
that but it's just a concern I have
um with the other recommendations there
are some interesting ones 13.
do we not have any benchmarking data you
know that surprises me that we're not
using benchmarking data and that really
must be an urgent consideration and I'd
urge that benchmarking data is made
available to members because we're not
Financial experts we don't know whether
a particular council is doing well on
this budget line it is the average is it
in the lower is it in the top percentile
you know the lower quartile where are we
compared with other authorities
um that would be very valuable certainly
to me
um number 19 and then I think I'll shut
up because Council of Durham's made
councilor down has made a very good
point about commercial income and I
absolutely agree with him you know of
all the places I've lived apart from
Cambridge I think Malden has fantastic
commercial possibilities because of its
Heritage it's it's facilities its
location you know massively under
exploited but number 19 consider
empowering parish and town councils to
take on more responsibility now without
dump jumping on the parishes I'm a
parish council as well as are a number
of us I think there's a lot there you
know because I feel in my Parish role
rather cut off from the district council
and I think there's tremendous potential
there for for working together with the
parishes to help us out of this
situation thank you
all members who wish to speak are spoken
anybody else Council Stevens
it's a very minor point it's not a point
of debate just a point of fact I said
earlier on that some of the groups have
been misnamed in appendix four of this
part on page 147 I don't know what can
be done now because this is a report
being put to us is it too late to just
amend that because it does refer to the
modern independent group and it should
say modern District independent group
please thank you thank you that's just
the point of clarity there so that's so
members we've got um we've got five
recommendations
six of my apologies over the page has
been alive a long evening
um
sorry Council driver please
I think the chair
um this is just really a request for
some clarification relating to
3.65 on page 110.
so it talks about the establishment of
the corporate finance board
which will own the corporate plan and
finance
and I just want to have some
understanding of what that in practice
means thank you thank you
um yeah through you chair thank you yes
that was the exact wording of the
recommendation from the peer reviewers
um but obviously in our response to that
recommendation we've taken into account
the Constitutional makeup of the council
and and that's why we've come up with
the proposal we have in terms of the
membership the name and the terms of
reference for the group to fit in with
iron Constitution thank you thank you
very much
councilor stilts and Council of um thank
you Mr chair I'm just trying to find the
bit that councilor spencerley was
alluding to which was about
assets and the town councils and it
actually says that we relinquish the
assets to
the town councils and parishes and that
could be the park so I'm sure Malden
Town Council would love to take on the
prom
uh councilor siddle please uh yeah thank
you chair so
um I I would like him to make a change
to the membership of the finance board
that councilor Paula spent to refer to
earlier
um and the fact that it is political
balance so therefore I would recommend
that we increase it to 10 for this many
Municipal Year and that there is an
additional member from the district
support group and an additional member
from the liberal Democrat group
is that seconded
is that second dude
okay so if when we vote on that motion
we'll take that forward councilor stem
you can um cancer still repeat that
please I didn't hear him exactly okay so
I'm putting forward a proposal that
councilor Paula spencerley put forward
which was that the finance member group
is politically balanced so therefore an
additional member from the liberal
Democrat group will be appointed an
additional member from the district
support group will be appointed
uh thank you chair can I just have
Clarity then on the finance is it a
finance board is it a finance working
group do the same rules apply if it's a
finance working group or a finance group
so anybody can attend when you have
these meetings I think it's really
important we know thank you
some time ago ask four questions none of
them have been answered thank you so um
I understand that the sort of difference
in terminology might be a bit confusing
so the the the terms that the peer
reviewers used was a board and obviously
within our constitution we don't have
kind of room for that for a board as
such so the existing Finance member
working group
um it was through discussion agreed that
um members would prefer to just call
that a um
a finance member group rather than the
finance member working group but in
essence the um mechanics of it would
work in the same way as a working group
at the moment so it the the essence of
of the group would still be working as
an as a working group it just wouldn't
it would just be called a finance member
group instead
chairman I'm I'm grateful for the the
comments of the 151 officer so from what
she says uh obviously um substitutes can
attend thank you unless of course
there's 10 votes or rule five or
foreign
yeah I'm just just to clarify on the
substitute's point I mean unless I'm not
aware of some resolution which maybe my
colleagues will be able to tell but
under the rules under the council
procedural substitutes
substitutes are for committees now of
course when you set up when members set
up a working group they can they can
appoint substitutes so and that's the
thing to do it's not an automatic
um right so and I think in the past
members have done that they've set up a
working group and then if a member can't
attend they there's a list of
substitutes that can take their place so
um substitutes can be worked into the
composition of the working group but
members need to decide on that it's not
it's not an automatic thing like it is
for committees
because the Constitution says it for
committed someone from the same
political group can be a substitute for
a member that doesn't apply to working
groups so if you want to have
substitutes then members need to
expressly deal with that
so that you do have a substitute
arrangement
and if the question was changed yeah or
does it start out okay I'm I'm corrected
by by Mr Dodson right yeah perhaps
so chairman the question was in two
hearts one was to do with substitutes
which I don't actually think was the
actual Hot Topic the hot topic was uh
um whether if it's a working group all
members are allowed to attend but not
those so I look forward to my invite to
the uh the way day if I'm available I'm
not sailing my boat thank you yes
um
yeah thank you very much I just wanted
to go to the monitor officer but I will
give way to the monster office to Mr
Johnson first of all thank you
yeah I I would need to confirm the
detail in the minutes if it's my
understanding and memory the uh the
statutory annual Council it was agreed
that substitutes can be allowed in
working groups okay okay
just let the monitoring officer you
anything to add no I'm I'm pleased that
that's what I wanted to hear that there
was something that made provision that's
fine in which case you don't need to
make express provision
um
um and I'm not sure what the wording is
but I'm sure it's it's clear
um the
working group Arrangement it my
understanding again unless my colleagues
again can tell me otherwise because
there's some resolution I'm not aware of
um don't be cool that members that are
although all members can attend a
working group
they're not really there to participate
they're there to listen
and and and and and so when we talk
about substitutes all members can come
it's not to to participate because
otherwise there's no point in having a
working group of limited members because
then the whole Council becomes the
working group
so so but but as Mr Dodson has clarified
there is a general provision that allows
for substitutes so it deals with that
point of substitution thank you
councilor Seattle please uh yeah just to
clarify the away day is for leaders of
groups
and for chairs of committee the finance
I know
with with LGA peers and and LGA offices
so there are two separate things
occurring
members thank you very much indeed
um we have with five recommendations
here but if we wish now we've got six on
on the recommendation two there's
been made a proposal earlier
okay
what was your proposal Council
sorry Council fluka
well do you know based on my experience
that's one job I never won again
um chairman what I proposed was that in
in the best interests of value for for
residents businesses and customers and
the protection of our residents cash
reserves the finance board stroke
working group delivers a cost neutral
budget for the municipal year 2024 2025.
I mean that is a huge ask but it really
is the outcome that we should aspire to
otherwise we're going to be taking you
know one and a half million quid of
taxpayers money to prop up our budget
um chairman I'm I'm happy to to to uh
um to add a word so that we can move
forward quickly and that would be to the
the finance board working group
Endeavors to deliver a cost neutral
budget
um because chairman at the moment the
health if the chairman if at the moment
the way this is all worded if they were
to improve things by one pound
um they would be successful so I don't
want to put too much on the the section
151 officer but for any moment we can
all pitch up about the meetings and
listen to what these clever people are
doing
um you know I think that's a fair and
proper directive from Council to try and
do this is what we should be trying to
do otherwise we will be the group of
people that has to borrow money in three
years time to to actually make this
Council work
thank you very much the only thing I
want to add is to which particular
recommendation you have been adding that
to I I see that as a new recommendation
and I see that as an additional one so
whether or not I'm proposing something
or whatever but I just think it's an
additional recommendation
um I mean it could be
[Music]
we seem to have lost it if you look at
the report there were six
recommendations and there were six key
areas in one area and then in in the
recommendation there's only five so
there's a bit of confusion there German
but I mean I I I posed this in the
spirit that that it's meant uh and and I
think it'd be a shame if it fell by the
wayside because of some procedure but
um perhaps chairman you you could
consider in allowing it as uh uh Romans
six uh and and that we all all of us
aspire to achieve that it's only an
Endeavor and a heartened that the the
leader like that one thank you very much
indeed I will accept that is that
seconded
Neil thank you but what I'm going to do
members now the debates come to an end
I'm going to take each of the
recommendations that are on the order
paper and uh so we're gonna go through
each one and we'll vote on each one
individually
um so first of all we've got little one
that the contents of the finance peer
challenge report at appendix a be noted
uh members is that agree by Sim noted
thank you
so we have now little two that the
council's response to the six key
recommendations one to six set out in
the draft Finance peer challenge planner
appendix to be approved
yeah okay I'd like my dissent noted on
that one number three that subject to
two being approved to delegate approval
of the council's response to other
recommendations 7 to 36 set out in the
draft member sorry the draft Finance
peer challenge action plan at appendix 2
to the finance member group
agreed thank you members little four is
subject to little two are being approved
to approve the revised terms of
reference to the finance member working
group a set out an appendix 3 as
detailed in the response to
recommendation 5 of the draft Finance
peer challenge action plan at appendix 2
is that agreed members
and finally well no there's another one
to come little five subject to two being
approved to approve the revised
membership of the finance member working
group as detailed in the response to
recommendation five of the draft Finance
peer action plan appendix 2 and
summarized at appendix 4 is that agreed
members there's an amendment to that to
make it 10 members ten members I
apologize uh Council
um
yeah that's is that agreed thank you
councilor chairman sir just to clarify
was that counts suspense you may
remember that the second big event
Council said to turn so I just want to
check that yeah it's the same motion
exactly yeah
thank you thank you very much indeed and
Council flute would you like to just put
your recommendation so that the clerk
can can capture it and then we can vote
on that
thank you I'm sorry to remember the the
members of this group with such another
aspiring Target uh that in the best
interests of value for residents
businesses and customers and the
protection of our residents cash
Reserves at the finance board working
group Endeavors to deliver a
cost-neutral budget for municipal year
2024-25 which I mean if it doesn't go
through bars then I'd like to I'd
propose a recorded vote thank you is
that seconded or is it a seconded but we
did agree by Ascent first of all
if I agree with members do you agree
that bison
create any descent group seems unanimous
in the chamber
um
they need to be appointed here okay
members
members thank you I apologize for the
length of the meeting members we will
probably go over 10 o'clock we have
incredibly important business to get
results tonight so I just want to
presence that
um we also now need to appoint those two
members
so we need one from the um yeah the
castle stilts
thank you Mr chairman I'd like to
nominate uh councilor Neil please
is that seconded
executive by councilor stamp so Council
Neil is by the district support group
thank you
councilor driver thank you chair I'd
like to nominate councilor Nick spinsley
is that seconded
seconded by Council Jennings is that
agreed members thank you very much
indeed and then we don't need anymore
that's it thanks members very very good
we now move on
to agenda item 17. which is a report the
median term Financial strategy update
and savings saving strategy this is
found on pages 149 and 152 and again I I
call on Miss Lucas please to present the
report
thank you shirt the purpose of the
report is to update Council on the
revised medium-term Financial strategy
position and to set out the requirements
to urgently identify savings strategy to
address that budget Gap
um
members will know that at the council
meeting on the 22nd of February of this
year the 2023-24 budget was agreed and
the NTFS projections over the next two
years were noted
um the budget for this year relied on a
drawdown from General balances of 421
000 pounds to fund the planned
expenditure for the year
a budget Gap in
2024-25 of
2.872 million was noted and that Rose to
3.5 million in 2526
and that was based on the assumptions
that were set out in the report of that
date
just like members to note that that
would have left General balances below
the minimum recommended level of 2.6
million next year and in a negative
position by 2526 which is obviously
unsustainable
so following the closure of the accounts
of the last Financial year and
subsequent to the findings of the
finance peer review which members have
just agreed and noted we have reviewed
the high level funding assumptions for
the current year and for the next two
years and they have been further refined
um in particular the business rates
position for the council has been better
than forecast and it is anticipated that
some of this growth can be built into
the Baseline position and this would
help to close the expected gap for this
financial year and would improve the
position in the subsequent years
in addition as noted by the peer review
um we have looked at the future funding
levels and revised some of our
assumptions around the growth in the
council tax base and the the level of
business rates going forward and taken
um together they result in a net
improvement in our anticipated funding
levels of 1.3 million in the next
financial year and just under 1.5
million in the financial year 25 26.
I would just like to say at this stage
that the other budget assumptions and
food including future cost pressures
have not been reviewed or refined in
detail at this stage but this work will
obviously be carried out as part of the
process and brought back to members for
further consideration at a later date
um so in the interests of time I won't
go through the tables at 3.7 and 3.9 of
the report but I'm I think they're
reasonably self-explanatory and just
show the improved position that I've
just um summarized
so just to move to paragraph 3.11 of the
reports
just to emphasize that
um even with that improved funding
position that's noted
um we still need urgent action to
identify a savings strategy
um and we need to set out clear
recommendations to address the budget
Gap and that also feeds into the
additional recommendation that was just
agreed by Council in terms of aspiring
to have a completely closed budget gap
for the next financial year
um so it is recommended that the finance
working group
um was tasked to lead on that saving
strategy and Report those
recommendations back and again that
recommendation has just been agreed so I
think the recommendations themselves for
this report
are really just to um for Council to
review the the position that I've set
out within the report
and also to agree that requirements
urgently identify the strategy to
address the budget Gap thank you Ms
Lewis thank you very much indeed there's
two recommendations uh just come to you
and captain second Council system thank
you a little one that the council review
the medium-term financial strategy mtfs
position and little two that the council
agree the requirements are urgently
urgently identify a saving strategy to
address the budget Gap to have a second
to please
second thank you councilor settle
councilor stamp please I now open the
chamber yeah oh thank you chair could I
actually ask when
um the costings we actually asked for
statutory and non-statutary services to
be costed we've actually asked for this
over a long period of time at different
Council whether it's strategy and
resources or I know it was mentioned at
PG a as well and it's been mentioned at
full Council and I know I saw a form of
some sort of form when Mr Leslie was
still here a lot of work was being done
behind the scenes now that is critical
information that needs to come to this
Council or the working group or whoever
it goes to I personally like to see it
to see if any more work's been done on
it I can't find my original email that I
got with the table on though so forgive
me Members otherwise I'd have shared it
before the meeting
um can I ask the officers when that will
be coming please thank you
Crusaders
um thank you chair yeah um I think as
I've previously said um one of the
committee meetings and that piece of
work is is ongoing at the moment and is
being actively looked at and refreshed
by officers
um obviously we were waiting on the
recommendation of the finance working
group being set up but the intention is
that that piece of work will be taken
back to that group at the earliest
opportunity for their consideration
um so I I don't want to make an absolute
um firm commitment that it will go to
the first one of those group meetings
but if not the first then definitely the
one after that so that work is ongoing
at the moment thank you thank you
Council fluka yeah thank you Jim first
question really is in relation to uh the
outcome for 2023
um
am I correct that had we have not had an
additional 400 000 pounds worth of
Interest received on our investments
which we should thank the toys for
crashing the economy for that
that our outcome would actually have
been almost 800
000 and secondly yes I remember the the
reports that Mr Leslie uh sent to
members uh some draft reports around uh
statutory the cost of providing
statutory and non-statitude services and
I've also received a report from Mr
Leslie about the the cost versus income
and the corporate projects team so uh
perhaps you could update members with
regards to that as well I'm quite happy
to show you the information that I've
got thank you
thank you
thank you councilor fluke
um yeah the interest income obviously
did contribute towards the the position
um that was supported for the financial
year last year 22-23 I would just
however make the point that
um the interest rates were high as a
result of the high inflation rates and
obviously that contributed significantly
to the cost pressures that the council
faced so it's a double-edged sword and
actually the fact that we gained on the
interest on the one hand it was probably
more than offset by the additional cost
pressures we felt as a result of that
inflation thank you thank you very much
indeed counselor Darren please yeah
thank you just very quick question
um we've seen today that the government
has agreed a public sector pay increase
is that going to impact on the mtfs
please
um through you chair thank you and the
local government's not subject to that
National um pay award we've got our own
pair award and that's um currently under
consultation with the Union so um yeah
that we won't be directly impacted by
that announcement thank you thank you
very much indeed members there's no more
hands so I need to move these
recommendations
um do I I'll move them both agreed thank
you very much indeed members
we move on to agenda item 18 which is
the provisional outturn 2022 2023 report
presented to the strategy and resources
committee on the 22nd of June 2023 this
is found on pages one five three to one
six eight uh I'd like to call upon the
leader to speak before we hand to miss
Lucas please thank you chair uh this out
return report has retrospectively been
approved for many years as it follows on
from the budget report approved at
February's Council and reflects previous
policy decisions made by the council and
its committees during prior years the
decision by strategy resources not to
approve the recommendations in the
report demonstrates how important is
that members seek clarification before a
committee and gain an understanding
before they attend officers are very
willing to work with members the develop
develop knowledge and assisting them in
any questions that they may have the
consequence if we don't do this it may
ultimately prevent the work work of the
council progressing I know from my own
experience that reports can contain a
lot of information and often complex
data that members are not familiar with
members should be reviewing the reports
in advance and as asking offers any
questions if they're unsure of the
details provided
the previous decision at SNR would have
a detrimental impact on Council
activities and projects especially the
funded work that we've committed to this
includes the work of the Burnham on
Crouch pontoon there are various factors
that impact the committee meeting and we
have learned from that situation if
there are particular items in the report
that members do have further questions
on it would make sense for these to be
discussed separately and if necessary to
request an amendment to the
recommendations to enable the rest of
the commitments to be approved and
implemented and the work of the council
to proceed so the recommendation is set
out to is that the council approves the
recommendations set out in the
provisional out term
22-23 report at appendix a Ms Lucas
yeah thank you um
I just wanted to draw a member's
particular attention to paragraphs 3.3
and 3.4 of the report
um where it states that it should be
noted by the council that um the
approval of the commitments um made by
the council and the carry forward of
those monies is required in order to
continue the normal operation of the
council and I just really wanted to
emphasize that point if the
recommendations aren't approved then
it's highly likely that the council will
be unable to fulfill all its statutory
and legal commitments and many existing
projects would have to cease or be
paused while a review of all those
commitments was undertaken and it should
also be noted that as many of those
commitments are funded by grants
um it may be and probably will be the
case that some of those grants would
have to be returned because they
couldn't be used for the purpose which
which they're intended
um in relation to the movement in
earmarked reserves noted at 3.4 again I
just want to draw members attention to
the fact that the majority of those
Reserve um use of reserves have already
been approved by Council um or its
committees
um during previous Financial years
um and therefore in the majority of
cases they are just for noting there is
a smaller number of Reserve movements
which were did form part of the decision
of that report for example the use of
the equalization reserve for council tax
and business rates which was to counter
timing differences in um in funding
um so um yeah I would just really um
urge members to consider carefully the
implications of not approving the um the
recommendations of of the report thank
you thank you very much Miss Lewis
councilor Fluker councilor stamp
be brief because I know it's 10 o'clock
and I'm very keen to support the
nighttime economy
um
one one could argue this item's already
been dealt with under delegated powers
of S and R but I mean I don't think and
it should go back there for review but I
think we all know the importance of
agreeing the recommendation uh tonight
um chairman given the political balance
of the council moving forward I hope
that in the future to give weight to
some of the comments the leader said uh
lead members will try and identify
issues in advance of agenda meetings and
after consultation with their
prospective political groups I always
remember all the agenda meetings we went
to we went we looked at trap doors we
looked at members where they were likely
to go and it avoided this sort of thing
and and I'll also ask officers and and I
I'm sure Mr quilts would come up with a
rule somewhere to support this but when
we're dealing with high impact corporate
recommendations
um
we always preface it with a
recommendation to council because this
could have come to council tonight as a
recommendation of the SNR that it had
been basically thrown out um Tim and
there are two items that I'm unhappy
about and both concern the drawdown of a
movement of reserves and members will
notice that
um the new homes bonus this is based on
the amount of new homes we built
um 390 000 pounds
um to to realize that some our residents
in Burnham South means the modern Hayes
Bridge have had to suffer massive
disruption including light noise and air
pollution and and basically there's no
other way of dressing it up basically
dirt for four years in South Minster in
appendix 3 it says that this pot of
money the new homes bonus is going to be
used as funding to support the general
fund pressures I.E that money for
building those houses is going to pop up
the council given sufferance around when
given the sufferance to our residents do
members that we really agree that
without some form of control that this
is appropriate and should be not at
least trying to try and spend some of
that 390 000 pounds you know on the good
folka haybridge for example to try and
give them a little bit of extra
infrastructure and likewise 421
000 received from the additional
business rates which in my mind could be
partly used to support and attract new
businesses to the district this is what
we've been trying to do now whilst I
accept that the general fund is under a
huge amount of pressure
um chairman to try and get some balance
in this and to try and get some
understanding by residents
um I'd propose that no funds from these
two reserves are allocated without the
approval of the strategy and resources
committee I mean that we know that we're
going to have to take we're going to
have to take some of this uh 900 000
pounds almost uh and use some of it to
pop up the the general fund but that's
what it says but I think members should
have a little bit of control over this
some we've already asked for the budget
and timeline for the local development
plan review which I know is coming
forward but I think this is right
chairman this is you know members
particularly with new homes bonus a lot
of people have suffered an awful lot
through the building program in the
district and I think that we should just
have a little bit more control over that
I I mean I know some of this money's
probably been allocated but this is a
new Council and I think we should look
very very carefully at how we spend
these pots of money
um
determine I made a proposal there thank
you very much indeed
Miss Lucas please hit
thank you and just clarifying the new
homes bonus Reserve so that was assumed
within the budget for the previous year
and essentially that money has already
been drawn down and used within the last
Financial year to to balance the budget
so members will note that the balance as
at 31st of March 2023 is zero so in
essence there is no money left in that
Reserve to utilize for a different
purpose so that one is really just for
noting I would make the wider point that
I have um in previous committees that I
I think it's unhelpful to view new homes
bonus as a specific pot of money in
relation to building new homes because
that is not the way that government is
treating it anymore it is just part of
the overall funding settlement for
government and they treat it as funding
available for the provision of General
services and as such that is how the
council has is treating it so um to not
use it in that way would just increase
the budget Gap further and in light of
the previous discussion and
recommendation about setting a balanced
budget for the future years I think
um not to use it in that way would
probably be unhelpful
um in terms of the business rates income
um
again a similar a point
um although we are expecting that
additional business rates income to come
in this year we are starting the
financial year in
um in a position where we were going to
have to draw down on reserves for that
amount and by by not using that income
for that purpose it will just leave that
budget Gap unaddressed and will increase
the um the pressure on the council to
find Savings of that amount for the
future years so in essence it will just
increase the size of the financial
challenge that members have to face when
looking to set that balanced budget
position which you've just agreed so I I
would advise
um from an officer perspective that
those monies are used for the purposes
which they are set out for in the report
which is to
um ensure that the overall general fund
of the council
um is balanced for the forthcoming year
thank you thank you
um no I just wanted to move to council
Stan please thank you
um I think Council fluke can make some
of my ideas even though we haven't
spoken about it because I actually would
like to see somebody go to the Fleur
delay view alleviation scheme I thought
we were actually putting money aside I'm
looking at Mr Dodson because I know that
we would discussed about trying to get
funding on Mr Holmes to try and get some
funding to contribute to the flooding
deviation scheme and the environment
agency because I thought my
understanding is that a deal has nearly
been done or we're not that short of
money so if we can somehow move some
money around or I don't know where
you're going to take it from I was
hoping with councilor fluka that we
could actually do that to actually
support the residents of haybridge but
before before I sit down because I
obviously Miss Lucas has just explained
we can't do that I'd like to ask um
cancer siddle why did you target Burnham
on Crouch well there's other other funds
that are going to be done so why did you
target Berlin on Crouch sorry I didn't
Target uh Burnham on crutch I explained
that the Burnham and Crouch was one of
those items that that we've received
funding field I can list some of the
other things if you'd like me to but it
was just an example of of the the but
the funding that we've received uh that
we weren't going to allocate for the
project that was that we've been given
it for so we would have been in an
illegal position in terms of that
situation and probably had to give the
money back in terms of the environment
agency they have the funding in place uh
for the floody alleviation scheme
um and that will be coming forward in in
the future and look to to complete so in
terms of that situation you're using
that money when the environment agency
is is is going to be allocating funds it
is not the right thing to do
thank you very much I think Mr Dobson I
asked Mr I didn't ask the leader that
question
yes but not that question respond thank
you
thank you chair through you the um
the position was I think
probably two years ago the council wrote
a letter of comfort to say that should
as as the flood alleviation scheme
um progressed through the business
planning process at the environment
agency that should there be a shortfall
then this Council would look to to
consider if if it was able to to help
with that at the time and that letter
helped in terms of progressing through
the business
um planning scheme that they went
through
and they progress to the next level and
subsequently put in an internal Fund in
bid for for the overall funding so my
understanding at the moment is that the
options that are on the table can
potentially be fully funded and that
they will consult on them in the coming
months
um
in supplementary to that there was an
agreement in the one of the first
reports that came through in relation to
one of the council's commercial projects
that should that go ahead and a capital
receipt be achieved then that would be
considered for the funding
if there was a shortfall if that makes
sense
the future I I think so but I still
think this Council needs to see it as a
priority because it has been going on
long enough
thank you any other members wish to
speak
my apologies Council Durham yes indeed
you did to councilor Durham thank you
yeah thank you um chairman the the
thorny subject of new homes bonus has
been discussed here many times before
um and we did to some stage several
years ago tried to resolve that we would
ring fence the new homes bonus that we
got for projects such as Council of Luca
described but then as now we weren't
able to do that because that money was
required to prop up the the general fund
it could be said had we have been more
enlightened with our commerciality back
then as indeed other authorities such as
Braintree had been who are able to
completely ring fence and use their new
homes bonus for things other than
propping up their um their general fund
we will be in a much better position
um but uh on on the back of that
we would also or we could also be
sitting here today in a much worse
position
had the last conservative fully
conservative Administration not actually
taken uh 1.8 million pounds out of the
uh out of their cost base we would be
really uh in in difficulty because
that's what we achieved
um back in about 2017 to 2019 uh
literally nearly two million pounds out
of out of our costs at that time but we
are not in the the fortunate position to
be able to use our new homes bonus
um for anything other than supporting uh
this Council and I'm really pleased
actually if Mr Dodson is correct that
the environment agency have agreed uh to
fully fund the haybridge flood
alleviation scheme I'm sure it's not to
the 11.4 million pounds that the
previous scheme uh that was looked at uh
will be and I would be very interested
to actually get details of that of that
scheme please thank you thank you very
much members we have a recommendation
too with the count Council approves the
recommendation Center the provisional
outer in 2022-20 uh no I'm not taking
any more questions thank you Council
2022 2023 report at appendix a is that
agreed by Ascent
agreed thank you very much indeed
members presume that includes my
um proposal that I made so thank you my
apologies
you put that proposal forward
yep that includes that thank you you're
welcome
okay members we moved to uh gender item
19 which is West Morgan Community
Association Management committee we need
to appoint one member of the councils as
representative on West Mall Community
Association Management committee for the
ensuing year and from the chair and
nominal counselor Shaughnessy seconded
thank you council is that agreed
unanimously thank you very much indeed
members thank you chair you're very
welcome thank you the members uh number
20 business by uh special circumstances
considered by myself to be urgent you'd
be pleased to know I have none members
thank you very much I draw this meeting
to a close at 10 15 and thank you very
much for your contributions please drive
home or walk home safely thank you